From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emilye Crosby with Mr. Charles McLaurin on December 5th, 2015 in daycare facility in the Indianola, Mississippi.
And this is part of the Civil Rights History Project, sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Charles McLaurin, thank you for talking with us this morning. I appreciate it.
Thank you for asking me.
Can you tell us when and where you were born and about your family?
Yes, I was born in Jackson, Mississippi in 1939.
My father, John and my mother Connie was, I guess, happy for me to show up on Christmas Day.
December 25th, 1939.
Because that was a time of war in the nation.
But my mother and my father finished high school and they worked as domestics.
And my father landed a job with the Coca-Cola Company.
And I think that was probably the best job that he had during his life.
He had worked at the sawmills, working in one of the sawmills in Jackson, Mississippi.
And those days sawmills were very important businesses.
And my mother worked domestic in homes of white people.
And as a cook at local restaurants in and around Jackson.
So my brother, A.C., and my sister Ella were the oldest.
I'm the oldest of the family.
In fact, I'm the first member of my immediate family to go to college.
So my grandmother, I lived with my grandmother for a while.
She was a school teacher, a guy had education over at Tuskegee.
And she would take me to school as a little fella.
She would take me to school before I actually got into the public school in Jackson.
I went to Smith-Robertson Elementary School, the first organized black public school in the state.
And so I got started out early with her trying to learn how to be what she wanted me to be.
My grandmother had one son and my mother.
And she always wanted my class son to go to school.
She bought him a lot of books and things.
As I'm growing up, she's passing these books and things on to me.
You know, books about Booker T. Washington and Booker T. Washington.
Of course, in this time, I'm not really into these books.
But since he didn't use my uncle didn't use them.
She just made them available to me.
And would often tell me about Mr. Washington and DeBores.
And the (George Washington) Carver, (George Washington) Carver.
These were her heroes.
Do you think that influenced you?
I think not as much as later.
I think what I really lacked most was Booker T. Washington.
She had a book about Booker T. Washington.
And she talked about this guy all the time.
And it kind of stuck with me a little bit because I admired the picture of him in the book.
And admired the way he was hair, you know, and he had beard.
And that he was articulate.
And that he had mostly educated himself.
So I think that's what stuck with me most.
That he was a guy who was a slave and didn't get formal education.
But along the way, he's getting educated.
And then he wound up, statesman.
He wound up speaking to the president.
And really pushing the role of black people in America.
But what are some of the important experiences you had growing up?
Well, there were numerous things that happened to me.
I think the one of the most experienced that really stuck to me that played a role later in my life
was my grandmother taught school at a little community outside of Jackson called Star Mississippi.
And she taught school in a church, a little church.
And she would take me to school with her.
We had to get up in the morning and take the local city bus into Jackson
and to the train station where all buses and trains got, buses came together then.
We would get off the local city bus and walk about three or four blocks to the trailways bus station.
And of course, this is doing period of segregation.
And we would go to our side, to the black side, get our ticket and everything.
And we'd go to school.
And then in the afternoon, we would repeat that.
The trailways bus would bring us to the bus station.
And then we'd walk the few blocks over to the train station where we'd get the city bus, local bus.
And on this particular day, my grandmother had to use the restroom.
So at the train station now in Jackson, the restroom for the colors will full up.
And there was a line waiting to go into the, you know, during these days there was always surprising to me that the bus station and train station stayed full of black folk, you know.
At this point, I don't understand why all of these black folks are there waiting on the trains.
And they've got boxes and suitcases and things like that.
And so my grandmother's got to go to the restroom and she took me by the hand.
And we walked across the corridor between the white and the black sides of the train station.
And my grandmother was tall about 5, 10, 5, 11, wavy black hair and blue eyes.
She was light colored.
So anyway, we go over to the white side of the restroom with my grandmother.
Just as we walk inside the door, my grandmother said, you stand here.
And I'll be right back.
I'm going to the restroom.
And I'm going to stay right here.
And those days when your parents told you to stay someplace or do some things, you did that.
Now I'm standing here and this big tall white man walks over to me and says, nigger, what you doing peeping at white women in the restroom?
Now the restroom was as far as at least, I guess, 20 feet from me, from where I was in this big,
I'm looking at him, you know, being a little fella and he's big and tall.
And he said, nigger, did you hear me?
Why are you peeping at white women in the restroom?
And I don't know what to say.
I'm in shock here, you understand?
I'm wondering what is the matter with this person and what is he talking about?
So by that time he's standing there talking a crowd starting together.
White people in that section of the station started to gather and they were all looking at me.
And my grandmother came back and as she walked up, she says, what's the matter?
And this man says, this little nigger boy has been peeping in the restroom at white women.
And my grandmother said, you alive just came out of the restroom and this is my boy and took me by the hand and lived me out.
Now he's in shock because he's wondering why this white woman is saying this, he thought she was white, you know.
And so we can leave the bus station and on our way home, my grandmother's talking to me about now, about segregation.
I'm not really understanding all of this.
I do know that when we get on the bus, we've got to go to the back.
Then when we go any place, we've got to go to the back.
Or we were in a section separate from where white people was.
And I just didn't think much about that.
That seemed like the ordinary thing to do. That was the way things were.
So now she's talking to me about racial segregation and about white people and stay away from white people, you know.
And don't talk to white people, you know.
What did you make sense of that?
I didn't. I just would want to do like she told them.
And stay away from them. And don't talk to them.
And stay away from white men especially.
And never, you know, be seen talking, acting friendly, talking white women.
And so I mean there's no problem.
So, but anyway, so the next day or two, when we would come to the bus station and catch in the train and anything,
I would just stay away from. So I was not around white people.
I lived in the black community and we had Farish Street in Jackson where we had all the kinds of things, you know, restaurants and clothing and juke joints and everything in our community.
There were little stores in the community where we lived, that blacks ran and everything.
So I'm not exposed to the white world really except when I step outside of that community.
So nothing's happening here now.
So that was one lesson that came back to me as I'm writing my story now.
And another incident happened. I was about, I must have been about 12 years of age.
I went to Lanier High School in Jackson and Marisee Jones Elementary School and of course Smith Robinson.
I didn't go to that school but a very short time because my mother and father separated.
And I went to live with my grandmother. My mother sits in brother's state with my mother.
But anyhow, now I'm in linear and in the afternoon, I had got a little job and a little store near where we live and afternoon.
And I would go there every day my job was to keep the front of the building clean because people, they provided curb service.
And sometimes people would eat white people with eat in their cars and they would sometimes stuff with fall off.
I'm to keep up everything around there, keep the boxes in the drain boxes with drinks and stuff like that.
And this white man who owned the store, he orientated me.
When I, as soon as I got there, he said, now, Charles, listen to this good.
He said, never answer the phone.
Never writing a thing now.
And when these, there was a group of white men who would gather there every day and sit and drink beer after they got off from their jobs
and drink beer and talk and laugh.
And so he said, when these men are in here, these skates don't get around in here then, and they're staying.
And what he's telling me is no problem. I'm getting $15 a week for doing like I'm told there.
And as I said earlier, when adults told you to do things back then, you did it that way.
It's close to that as possible.
Well, it was white or black. And saving my mother, my grandmother had told me to stay away from white people and spend around me.
So he's just kind of telling me what I've already heard.
So I'm there working one day. The manager, the man got sick and he had to be out for several days.
And had this young white lady running the place.
And so I'm standing around outside there waiting and making sure that everybody needed to do that.
And the white lady told me, she said, Charles, I'm going to be in the back doing some inventory.
And you just watch after the front. So all that meant was watch after the front.
And so while she's back there, the phone rang.
And, hey, nothing to me, the man told me to never answer the phone.
And he stressed the never. And so the phone keeps ringing.
Keep ringing. And one of these white men back there said, hey, nigga, you hear that white?
You hear that phone ringing?
I didn't say nothing. I just kept doing what I was doing. Nothing.
And so he said, nigga, get that phone.
Now I'm kind of torn between whether to answer that phone or just leave it alone.
But he said it in such a way that it was a demand.
So I said, okay, I walk over there and I pick up the phone.
And somebody called an in who wants to give an order and they're going to come pick it up.
Because we did provide curb service and stuff like that.
So the items they wanted, I break another room.
And I reach over there and get this pencil and write these things down.
And, okay. And so after we finished writing it down, I turned and start to start the storage room
where the white lady who's in charge is.
And she's coming taught me down. And we kind of meet up just kind of opposite of where these eight or ten white men are sitting.
And I'm reaching that note out. And one of the white men grabbed that note out of my hand and said,
nigga, you black so and so, you are giving a note to a white woman.
And I'm, man, I've already started out breaking all the rules that the man told me and I took, and here too.
And now I've got another surprise here is that he's taking the note and he's telling me that I'm giving the note to the white woman.
And that's true. I am handing the note to the white woman. But he had a different, you know.
And so, and he took the note and he looked at it.
And he passed the note around to these other white men and then came back to him.
And he said, black ass and he said, nigga, you wrote this? I'm still not talking now.
So, he said, nigga, you wrote this and that white lady walked up and she said, child's going to school.
And he looked at me and he looked at her. And he said, I'm talking to this nigga. I'm not talking to you.
And he said, black ass, nigga shouldn't have never held a pencil in his hand.
And I'm standing here. I don't know if I've already pissed on myself or not, you know.
Because I haven't said anything. I don't know what to say. I'm shocked.
And the white lady reached and got the note from him and said, child, you wait outside.
Man, from where that spot to the door. I don't know how far that is. But wherever it was when I hit the ground, I was running toward home.
And got home and told my mama. And now I'm getting a lesson from her about Ku Klux Klan, about white men, lynching black men.
And now I'm getting another lesson here from my mama. She told me to don't go back.
That I'll see about your money. And so I never went back. And that situation was now...
I'm thinking now with a little connection toward what my grandmother told me back there. See?
And then I had another... We are now up in the... We are up in the...
Do you want to continue this?
You're told that you're running.
So on this come back, you said there was another incident.
Yeah. This other incident involved...
My friends and I were walking to Jackson into the city. We lived in Jackson, but we were on the houseguards.
And this white man stopped us. And he ran a furniture store. We would pass him by this furniture store.
And he said, hey fellas, do you all want to help me and make a little money? And we said, yes.
So what he was doing was having an auction furniture. And he was doing it over in Rankin County.
We were in Hines County, Jackson. And he had this store over in Rankin County.
So he said, y'all load up on the truck then. And we got on the truck and he took us over into Rankin County.
And to his furniture store. And he said, now tomorrow we're going to be selling furniture here.
And y'all's job will be to put it out. And we'll tell you what to put out.
And then when people buy the furniture, then we'll put it back. Put their names on it.
And then when we have finished, you will deliver it to them at their homes.
And so we got out there and we were working. And I'm about 17. I'm almost 17.
Because what had happened was I had earlier, I'd been in the Army Reserve.
And I had on this old Army shirt. And it had a PTC stripe on it.
That's the first grade of something in the Army, the Rankin.
And I had taken it off. It was just wearing the shirt.
So as we were bringing furniture in and out, in and out, as I walked out the store this day,
a little white man walked up to me and he said, nigga, what are you doing with that shirt on?
Hey, again, I'm shocked. I mean, everybody got on the shirt. You know, most people wearing shirt.
Yeah, I would've been in trouble there. So he said, ain't that Army shirt you got on?
Well, you know, in the other words, I'm no longer... I had done six months active duty training in the United States Army.
And I'd been released to the reserve. And I was going to reserve unit periodically.
But this shirt was an old shirt that I just... anyway, he said...
How ignorant about some of the Army stuff? So did you take it off because you're not supposed to wear it if you're not active duty?
Well, it had been said that you wasn't supposed to wear them when you were representing that, you know,
that was... when you put on the shirt, that was... had these insignias that were going on the collar on the shirt somewhere.
But a lot of other people were... these were old shirts that really was discarded.
And a lot of men who had got out of the Army were wearing these old shirts. And, you know, I had seen them.
But he said... that stripe... wasn't there a stripe on that shirt? I said, yeah, still was.
And he said... that mean that you were over men.
I said, not necessarily. He said, did you... were you over white men?
I said... you know, that gave me a little rank if there were those people who were without one of those at all.
Well, the thing maybe I had, you know, I was kind of over them. He said, well, they white men.
I said, somehow I'm doing one white. And he said, let me tell you this.
He said, nigga, I don't want to see you back here in that shirt. No more.
So don't you... if I see you in that shirt this evening, after lunch, I don't know what I'm going to do with you.
And so I looked at him and I could see he had a gun on him, hosted gun.
But he was wearing a regular shirt. And then there was a little old badge on him that said constable.
I didn't know what the heck a constable was, you know. And so he left.
And I came back into the store and I told the white man who run the store.
I told him and he said, well, I tell you what. He said, don't you go back outside.
Today you work inside. Don't you go outside for nothing. And that said, okay.
No problem with me. After all, I'm working. We make a little something.
And so after we left that day, the next morning, when we all reported to work, he told me he couldn't use me.
He said, because there was going to be some trouble. I couldn't figure out what trouble there was going to be.
He said, there's going to be some trouble. And I tried as hard as I could and I said, what kind of trouble?
He said, no, just you know, we can't use you no more. So I go home and I tell my mom about this.
Now I'm getting another lesson here about the Clue Clark's claim about these white people who just don't want to see blacks advance.
You got on a shirt there and then the army, you know, they were not too long ago.
The army was desegregated and they're white men who don't want to be led or supervised by blacks.
And so chalk that up to them. And so that now will up into right at the 60s. Right at the 60s.
How did you get into the service where you drafted or did you sign up?
Well, one afternoon, some of my friends and I was just goofing off. We had played hooking from school.
And there were two of us guys of our group. I think that was five of us this day.
And two of them wanted to go to the army. And one of them said, let's go sign up for the army. I said, no, I don't want to go to the army.
So that's the part of this. So we go to, he said, well, just come on, go with us up there.
So we go up there to the federal building and recruit a talks to us.
And he said, okay, you two guys want to go. And so we got a test that you.
And he said, I said, well, I'll wait over here. He said, I'll just go on and take the test.
And you got to go to the, you don't have to go because they, even if they pass, they would have to sign some papers or something like that.
So you wouldn't have. And so we went on into the place and we gave us the test. And we came out.
And the two guys who wanted to go didn't even pass, you know. And he said, well, you have made enough to get in the army.
And I believe we must have been around 10th or 11th grade. That's when we were in the 8th, 9th, 10th grade.
It was somewhere around the 9th or 8th grade, 10th grade, somewhere and there like that.
Because I tried, as I'm writing my story now, I've been trying to remember how this all came about.
And then as I'm writing now, I'm learning things about myself that I never even thought about that I did.
Okay. But anyway, he said, you made enough to get into the army reserve and say, what you would do, you would be if you decide to go.
It would be around October and this was in the summer. This was like June or July.
And he said it would be a training cycle in October. And you would go, you could go for active duty training for six months.
And then you get out and you have a chance of re-enough. For the regular army or you could just go and be, we would release you to a reserve unit in your community.
So I said, well, I don't know. So later on, one day, this recruiter came to the office somewhere around about September and asked if I was interested in going.
Now, I've had some experiences here that I wanted to get the hell out of Jackson. Now, I'm ready to get out of Jackson, Mississippi.
I'm ready to lead the style. And this is often an opportunity to get out of Jackson.
But my mother told me not to take this. Just to nod on, you need to stay in school.
And so I had to have the signature of one or both of my parents. And my mother wouldn't do it. And so I went to my dad.
Now, my dad wasn't able to get into the army and back in the war because he had a cripple. He had a foot that had been born with some kind of deformative in his left foot.
And so he couldn't get into the army. So he really resented that. He really wanted to go.
You know, when people were going to the war, black a lot of black people got into the army and the Navy to get away from Mississippi and to better lives and some opportunities.
But so my dad did. I went to my dad with it and signed me up.
And I take my papers and turn them in. And there one day, I've almost forgot this whole thing.
And one day this recruiters showed up at the school and Lanier High School where I was and said that this training session was coming up in October.
And these are your credentials, gave me a pile of papers. Now I'm really hesitant about this now because I didn't really forgot about this.
But then when I think that this gives me a chance to get out of the state. So I said, OK, I got ready.
And so I had already been and taken this six months active duty training. And that's why I got hold of this shirt.
So was it was your training integrated?
This was just kind of the star. This was around 1955. And the army had just been desegregated. The national.
Some whoever was president then had signed the order to desegregate. Because when I got there, you could tell that there were transition in from a segregated army because of the barracks and the way things were set up.
And then they were talking about, you know, have not having had black officers in situations over whites and stuff like that.
I like for you. First, it was it was it was a surprise because I never expected to be in the company or the presence of whites.
You see them said, I'm been told to stay away from them. You know, that's what my mother and everybody. And we lived in our little world, coming to black until we had to go over into the white section for something.
You know, work or really for nothing else because we had everything we needed over here.
But I'm kind of now I'm kind of torn between my early lesson and what is now facing me.
Here I am in I'm in a unit when we arrived in the first place I went to was Fort Jackson, South Carolina. And this was around 1955.
And there had been some demonstrations in the NAACP, COLA and some of these organizations had been demonstrating and had been some riots or something that had happened.
But I wasn't all aware none of this merge. But I could hear this through people talking. Some of these kids who were coming here from Florida and New York and California and all around who were coming who were here.
And so the first day there at Fort Jackson, South Carolina, I got dumped out of the bed. I was on the top bunk. I get dumped out of the bed on the floor by the sergeant.
Because we were supposed to be up and you had to get up and make up your bed and make sure your shoes are shine. And the sergeant came by and dumped up a half a dollar or a quarter or whatever.
It was supposed to get that bed and that bed was supposed to be and your shoes got to be and all of the things got to be arranged a certain way in the foot locker.
And so here I am, get dumped off on the bed and this guy is yelling at me to get out in this formation and your bed ought to be straightened up. You should have do this.
And so I finally wound up out there in the formation. And so then we were out there for a while, then we were going to breakfast. And so now and the sergeant over this group is a white man.
And so after breakfast then we were going on a march. And the way they lined you up, they put the tall man in the front line. And you know it kind of came down to the little guy to the short guys like myself.
And so I'm finding trouble here walking because now every, it's supposed to be 30 inches all around you. But the front guys with the long legs are stepping it off.
So I'm back there trying to keep up in the sergeant and get in line, shape up there, you know.
And so the first chance I get, I write a letter to my congressman. You know, I found out who my congressman was. The guy by the name of John Bail Williams in Mississippi.
And I found out about friends out about him. So I'm writing a letter trying to get out. I'm telling them I'm on the age. And all this and get me out of here. And so I thought I was going to get out in a while.
So I'm not really doing all that I suppose to do. I'm still booking. You know, I'm still getting harassed and hollered it because I'm not exactly getting my bed right.
And the sheet, he comes sergeant coming and snatched his sheet and all that stuff over my bed and throw it out on the floor. And I got to get it up and put it back together.
And so after a while, I let it come. I don't, I never see the letter. But the letter came. And when I went to the office, the letter is being read to me by sergeant.
That sergeant, whoever was there, he said, the congressman answered the letter. And he said that as a little black boy from Mississippi, you ought to be proud to be able to wear the uniform of the United States Army.
And therefore your exit from here is denied. He said, you got the soldier. You're going to soldier. So now I got to now make up my mind that I'm here. And I got to shape up. And I'm not going to be able to ship out.
So this is that experience happens. So that's why I had this Army shirt because it was left over from that period when I did that training. And that has been a long time between 1955 and we are up to 1960, you know, right at 1960.
So the old shirt now I had gone to a few reserve meetings in Jackson, but that was still segregated.
So the training was integrated, but the reserves, once you get up in Mississippi, it's still segregated. Yeah, it's still segregated here. But again, Mississippi was segregated. And so now I don't have no real problem about this.
Then the next thing that happens is that freedom writers are coming to Jackson. We're up to around 1961, 6 to 61. And I've been reading about the, you know, the going zone out in North Carolina, Greensboro,
Williamsburg, and those places where, and you know, and about now I'm a little bit more interested because I kind of understand the NAACP a little bit. I heard a Medgar Evers of us.
Are you in school at this point? Yeah. Are you at Jackson State or are you still in high school? I'm still at high school. See because when I left, I was away for six months. And then I came back. And the first thing I want, right, my mom had me to do was go back and roll in school.
And now I want to be in school because while I was there in the Army, I learned what I didn't know. I found out that I was not ready, not only ready for my Army.
I really wasn't ready for nothing as far as the world's concerned. And I can now, as a result of that Army experience, I can see beyond Jackson.
I can see beyond my immediate community, you know, where I kind of expected to grow up and really hadn't thought about what I was going to be or what I was going to do or what kind of direction to take.
But now that I'd been in the Army and I saw my shortcomings, I saw that I did not know had not been exposed to some of the things that these people who were there who had come from these various other states. And I was not prepared.
So I come back, I go right back, I go to high school, I go back to linear, pick up that. Okay. And then one of the things I learned was that there was a high school equivalency examination that you could get.
I didn't know how to go about doing under this at that point. And then when I finally get that information, you know, I stood this and think about doing it. But in the meantime, the freedom rise comes to Jackson.
You were mentioned by this time, you know about the NAACP and Medgar Evers L, which can you tell us how you found out about that and what you thought about it?
Yeah, what happened was the, I learned about Medgar Evers, because Medgar Evers lived in the community where I lived in kind of like Georgetown, Mississippi, you know, out of North West Jackson.
And my friends and I were one afternoon hitchhiking a ride from our community Georgetown down into Jackson to the Farah Street to the theater.
And we were picked up by this tall handsome man that I didn't know and they didn't either. But we didn't, we were just getting the ride to downtown.
And so two, three days later after we in the newspaper, his dismay, Meg Elvis, who was the NAACP leader. And so when that happened, then I kind of got interested in this organization.
What is the NAACP? My grandmother had mentioned it back there, you know, and this stuff didn't stick to him because it wasn't important.
But now I want to know who little more about the NAACP. And so my friends and I had went out to Medgar's office out on the ministry.
He had told us where his office was and everything out there. And so we go out there and we get to talk with him and some of the people in his office and they had a youth chapter and that kind of stuff there in Jackson.
And then I didn't keep that up. I didn't continue to go to these meetings and everything because we already had our kind of junk we were carrying on.
You know, our rivalries between black communities. I went to linear and there was Jim Hill high, linear high and Jim Hill high. So there's a rivalry between these schools in basketball, football and track.
And pure article we get to fight after the game, initials to kind of a little something we wanted to do. And then one night after a basketball game at linear, some white kids drove through our community through by linear and through Rodney's on our building and on us and things.
But we decided that we were going to retaliate now. We were going to yeah, yeah. See now nobody had our people that told us to stay away from them. And they had told us to respect white folks because they were I guess. But now here we are.
They hadn't told us about them doing things to us. We heard of the clan. We knew they did. We didn't see ourselves as those people that got lynched. You know, Mack Charles Parker and Emmett Till and all of that. And so we loaded up one night and got riding the eggs and coke bottles and things and decided we were going to retaliate.
And but when we went through the area where these white kids usually be, there was they weren't there. So we put that off. But then there was some other kind of things that was going on that Medgar Evers.
And so we went back to talk and told Medgar Evers about what had happened and everything and he talked about what they were doing with the NAACP was doing. And all of a sudden freedom arrives. These people are coming into Jackson.
They've been a bomb and over in barring ham and people were beaten. And this this was kind of exciting to us. But it didn't mean nothing really to us because that's what these people coming to do this. And because we didn't know nothing really much about that.
But of course now we know that the freedom ride and the destination was to be New Orleans. But they never got out of Jackson because they got arrested there and got put in jail and stayed there. And the city of Jackson and the state of Mississippi were planning to break the NAACP and core these organizations by making them put up these bonds and not giving them that bond money back and really not doing anything about the cases.
So as these freedom riders that started to get out of jail and going home. One of these freedom riders named James Rev. James Bevel, James Rev. James Bevel, went to work for Southern Christian Leadership Conference. You know, SNCC was formed.
And Gallabagha had brought the SNCC people together and had brought the demonstrators from the world worst city ends and other city ends together. And they had formed the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee or SNCC. All right. But again, we didn't know nothing about any of that except Rev. James Bevel comes in one night. And he come into our community in Georgetown where we lived to the pool hall where we hung out.
We were getting ready to have a rivalry battle between the West Jackson kids who mostly went to Jim Heo and the linear kids who lived over on Georgetown. And we were assembling our weapons and bottles and bricks and Rev. James Bevel come in and he sat around.
We saw this stranger come in. You know, we didn't know who he was and he's sitting around as we were planning and talking. And then just as we were about to load up and go kick get Keel, put in jail or whatever. And he hopped up on a pool table and said, hold it.
He said, you all you're brave. You're bad. You're going to go out there and kill one another. Shoot up one another. He said, is there any of you bad enough to buy a ticket at the bus station on the white side of the bus station.
And so some of the guys said, we didn't got no money. It's no word about money. I got the money. If you got the nerve to not fight among yourselves, but go to I'll take you to the bus station. You're going to buy a ticket to New Orleans. And you'll be met in New Orleans by.
So several of my friends said, yeah, I'm about to get and one was James Jones, Ralph Floyd, Levin Brown and a guy by the name of Charles Cox and two or three other people. But James Jones and Ralph Floyd was my friends and you know, buddies and pals.
And so they were all took them down. We didn't we didn't fight. We didn't we didn't go ahead with the battle. We took this challenge.
And so did you know what he was doing? No, no, I didn't. He didn't give us a lot of information because he was the challenge that he had thrown at us. Yeah.
And so these guys, they didn't think they were going to get put in jail really. I didn't really just took the challenge. And I guess they were going to come back onto the block with the rest of us tomorrow next day.
So if Rev. James Bevel told, I don't think he told them they were going to jail. We never told them that. And and they wouldn't, you know, and we really wasn't smart enough to see the relationship between these people who are the people who have been coming and getting put in jail and us getting put in jail in there. They got put in jail because they came to cause a problem.
And so we didn't connect that. But anyway, the next morning, the newspaper Jackson, the news and the Clarion- ledger news papers had in there that these fellas, my friends, they were in jail. They were arrested.
And Rev. James Bevel came back and talking with us again, trying to get some more of us to go. I couldn't see that. One of my concerns here now was that there are problems between blacks and whites. And there are a lot of things going on that I don't understand.
And but one of the things the Emmett Till had happened and we have been very made aware of Emmett Till because of the sensational photographs that came in the Ebony magazines and the Jet magazine. And it pissed us off. We were angry about this, but that was all it was, you know.
So, some people say seeing that picture on the frame.
No, we wanted to get together a group and go up there and find these guys. We sat on the corner one night after we, and we didn't know what the Delta was.
And we sat on a block there and talked about going to try to find them, going up there to the Delta.
No, we, one of the things that was no fear in us, we didn't fear white folks, you know.
It's just that we've been taught to stay away from them. Don't get involved with them, you know, except if you've got a job, you go to work and you do your job, and you get paid and you go home.
You don't socialize us, nothing with them. And so, but we wasn't afraid of them.
You know, our parents and people had the fear of us being lynched or something.
And that fear was not something that they had passed on to us.
They had given us lessons about how to live and not about fear and whites.
Because, you know, two or three times, you know, they threw the eggs on us. We were going to go and retaliate.
So, every time they did something, something happened to our folk. We got ready to deal with it.
So, that, with Rev. James Bevel coming out now and getting us together, kind of caught us out thinking to come around.
And him telling us about explaining now the cityans and the beatings and the buss and core.
We learn now about core and SNIC and the NAACP and about Morehouse College.
Because this is one of the colleges he talked about a lot, Rev. James Bevel did, and talked about Spellman and how at the university.
And like that. And so, now, as he's coming back and my friends are getting out of jail,
we now are trying to think about what we can do. You know?
We're thinking about what we can do now that they are out of jail. These other people are out and they're gone.
So, it was decided that we would develop a movement in Jackson.
Did Rev. James Bevel have any workshops on non-violence to each try to do that with you?
Not at this point. It wasn't really done any good. Teaching us not to retaliate.
No, he didn't deal with that at this point. Rev. James Bevel was a swoon little fella. And I admired it.
Because he reminded me of my grandmother talked about, yeah, Booker T. Washington and Booker T. Washington.
And about the difference in their philosophy about segregation and integration and stuff like that at a very small level.
But now Rev. James Bevel is talking about these things and he's talking about the overall picture of the civil rights movement.
So, then he said, we'll develop a movement. And we decided to make it the Jacksonville, Jesse Harris, who was one of my friends,
who had went on the freedom ride, too. I forgot Jesse. And Jesse was into this non-violent thing.
Yeah, because this happened that kind of involved us and it was kind of hilarious, too.
Jesse, when Jesse was arrested for trying to buy a ticket, they had, the city of Jackson had not yet been kind of conditioned to the federal governments involved in this effort.
So, Jesse Harris, they sent Jesse to the counter-phone. He was arrested. They sent him to the counter-phone.
And Jesse told us, now this is him back. He says there was a sign up over the gateway to the counter-phone.
And it said, we break your spirit, we break your behind.
And so, he said that was crossed the gate. I don't know about it all day, but this is Jesse talking.
And he says, so he was there and they had a work crew that go out every morning to work cutting their grass along the roads and byways and everything, picking up trash and just doing whatever way for Wings you do.
So, when they get up in the morning, after they have their breakfast, they had to line up and count off before they went on the bus.
And they said that when you got ready, you're on the bus. And then when you, as you're getting off of the bus, you say, you count off.
Nigger one, Nigger two, Nigger three right on down through whatever the number is. So, Jesse was the fourth person, I think he said, fourth person.
The guy before him stepped off and said, Nigger one, Nigger two, Nigger three. And Jesse just stepped off of the bus. And the other guy went on counts. And it sawed him fighting his holi.
And they said, bring that nigger back. So, y'all get back on the bus. Having to count off. Stepped off of the bus. Nigger one, Nigger two, Nigger three.
Jesse just stepped off of the bus. And they got to go, hold it, bring him back. They brought him back to third time. And when the fourth time he didn't sound off, said to the side and it said, stretch him.
And they said, get him over there on this big table. Just to say they had a big table. And they had one big burly black guy that kitchen bodies his heel, his ankle.
And another one that grabbed him up there at the front. And they had a guy there, black guy with a strap. He said it was about four or five inches wide. And it was short. And it had two holes in it.
And it sawed him and it was a gilded signal. And he wrapped him across his butt with that strap. And then they wrapped him about four times.
And they put him back on that bus. Put them back on the bus. And they fell off. And Jesse said he was in pain. But when he came off of the bus, he still didn't.
And he was patching him. Carried him back over there and gave him about $10-$15 of the licks between his bottom of his butt up to his shoulder.
Put him on the bus. Put him on the bus. And they were coming home. And this guy said, nigga one, nigga two.
No, just a diggin' folk.
Before they even got to it, no.
And that's why I say it was the laughable kind of situation.
You know, the way he told it.
And you know, Jesse was tall and the way he talked.
And he's serious.
And so now, we're developing this move.
And so what happens is Medgar Evers and Rev. James Bevel, die and nash.
And I believe Chuck McDew and some others.
Some of the people who had been in McComb with Bob,
who came with Bob, you know, down there, who went to McComb later.
But anyway, we're developing this movement.
I think he may have been the chairperson of something.
Yeah, Paul Brooks.
That was a guy who never talked.
And he seemed like he'd argue with stop signs.
I mean, he really talked all the time.
There was another Lester McKinnie.
And the mayor, the mayor and mayor, you know, these guys.
And they were talking all the time, you know, and they were debating.
But anyway, Medgar Evers is involved here.
Now, Medgar Evers comes into the picture as we're setting up this Jackson movement.
And so, dying National, if you set up this movement,
and then we were going to have a meeting, this is around 1961.
I'm in mid, some way over in the summer here now, moving towards 1962.
And they said that, are you in high school still?
What are you doing at this point?
Are you working?
I'm working.
I had gone to high school, and then I had decided then that I was going to take this equivalence.
Examination.
And I was in 11th grade now, I think around 11th grade.
And that's summer, at least summertime now.
And so now it's the, I have learned now that I can get this test down the Mississippi Valley State University.
So, what happened now, what I did during that summer was help work with this movement.
And then in 1961, after the Freedom Riders had been through that,
I, I would group decided that we were going to attend the state,
previously segregated, previously segregated fair in Jackson.
And we were to meet at a certain place and go to the fair.
There was four of us, both of you going.
And we were supposed to meet.
So we met, no, the meeting didn't come off because these guys didn't show three of the four of us who was supposed to go, didn't show them.
And then I went on down to the fair and tried to buy a ticket to the fair.
And they turned me away.
So in your mind, what's the difference between going down to the bus station for a ticket and going to the fair?
Why would you really do the one?
Because I wanted to go to the fair.
See, they, they, they, they, going to the bus station was not going to get me nothing, but arrested maybe.
And, and I wasn't thinking about that.
But the fair, I had watched the, the fair coming to town.
Now we had a black fair and a white fair.
And we couldn't go to the white fair.
And the white folks ran the one we had.
But, and I don't know that.
And it was over.
And this is the week that the white fairs coming.
And they're advertising it as a state fair.
This is a fair for the whole state.
And they all come, you know, schools and everything are coming to the state fair.
Plus, several of my friends had got jobs helping to set up this fair down at the fairground in Jackson.
And I had come around sometime, where they were.
And saw all of these things that's going to be at the fair, you know.
And we didn't have one of these back at the Blacks' hands.
And they were going to have, they had a burless show.
And I was really going to go to the burless show.
And because, you know, legally, I don't know if I could because what am I now around about 18, 19, somewhere in there.
And I don't think I think you had to be 21 to go to the burless show.
But I was on the age, but I was assured that I was going to get a chance to go because of my friends and these people working there.
And I had found a way to get in by slippin' in.
You know what I'm saying?
Yes. See, back when I was growing up, I was not a fearful person.
And I was always looking for the opportunity to do something I wanted to do.
And I'd be told, you know, and guided by it.
So, but anyhow, I made up my mind.
I wanted to go to the fair for entertainment and all of the goodies.
And so, I decided the four of us had decided that we were going to go.
Now, these guys had already charged Cox, Levin Brown, and something about it.
And what Jesse went with it, the Ralph Floyd.
And we were going to go to that.
And in the meantime, we were trying to get together this Jackson movement.
Our guys, Medgar had a group of NAACP kids that he was working with out of Tougaloo,
But they, I don't think they had on their agenda, you know, the background.
They were going to go to the library.
So, anyway, I went down there, tried to buy a ticket.
They told me, I, the negatives ain't your fair.
Your fair was last week. Get your son so away from here.
And I thought about it. I said, well, I walked away.
A little piece from the ticket area.
And thought hopefully by now my friends would have decided that they're coming.
And they, we would meet. And I waited around a little while and I went back.
And the lady said, nigga, we've told you to get away from here.
You ain't going to this fair.
And if you don't get away from here, we're going to call the police.
So, I stepped off again and thought about it.
And now I'm kind of angry because I wanted to go to the fair.
They said, this is a state fair. They all come.
And so, I decided to go back.
They called the police.
Police came, put me in jail.
Now, I'm in jail because I couldn't go to the fair.
Now, I'm thinking, now, this, a lot of stuff is coming clear to me.
See, it took a long time to beat this into my head.
I'm telling you.
Because I didn't want to do wrong, really.
And, but at the same time, there was something standing in my way to what I wanted to do.
Always, there was something.
Anytime I stepped outside of the perimeter set by my parents, my people, Black folk,
I get cut off.
And I can't go.
Okay. So, anyway, I'm in jail.
Next day, the jailer came to me and said, nigga, there's a nigga down there in the courtroom to post your bum.
I'm thinking maybe it's Jesse or some of them, you know.
I get down there.
There's this handsome, black, well-dressed man sitting there with his leg crossed and the brief can't sit down beside him.
And I remember, I'd seen this man before.
This is Mad Gellers.
And so, he's posting my bum.
We lead.
And he's talking to me all about this Jackson movement coming up and talking to me about a workshop that was going to be at Mount Beulah,
over the Edwards somewhere near Edwards.
There was going to be hell about voter registration and about civil rights and that kind of stuff.
And I told him that I would be glad to go.
So, anyway, we went on and we were working now.
This thing happened at Edwards.
And it's a white boy, a white lawyer named William L. "Bill" Higgs, who was in charge of this.
He was a former legislator, I think, in Jackson.
But he had brought down some lawyers from up north and they ran this workshop.
Now, I can go ahead.
So, I'll clear the back.
William L. "Bill" Higgs comes up a lot in this part of the story.
Do you have any idea of what motivated him to, he's like a name like the Mississippi, right?
Any idea of what motivated him to be in the movement?
No, I really do not.
No.
Now, I think he had gone to school at Harvard or somewhere.
I'm not sure, but I believe he had a Harvard Law degree and he had served in the legislature.
I believe.
Because I didn't think much about that except that I was surprised that these white lawyers were teaching us.
You know, because in Mississippi, we only had three black lawyers, our just brown, car, sand, hall, and Jack Young senior.
And so, why these white boys teaching us, we don't have no blacks.
I don't guess, or whatever.
But now, all this has fall from my mind because now I'm focused on what can I do?
What is it that, why can't I do what everybody else can do?
Why is it that white folks can do this?
And I can't do nothing.
I really, tilled, had been lynched and there had been other lynchings.
And nothing happens with that.
So, Martin Luther King was coming to that.
The movement had set up to have Martin Luther King come and speak at the Masonic Temple in Jackson, Mississippi.
This is around the latter part of 1961, almost in 1962, if not already 1962.
These guys begged him right now.
But King came and spoke.
And he had these SNCC people with him, Diane, and a lot of SNCC people who I heard of earlier now come and they are around and with King.
And King, I heard about King, read about him in the Montgomery bus boycott and Rosa Parks and this.
And I never thought I'd ever get a chance to see this man in person.
But he is in Jackson, Mississippi.
And he's here with these SNCC people, and I'm with these SNCC people.
And he gives a speech.
Now I heard Medgar, and I thought Medgar was the greatest there was.
And you know, how he, you know, the auretor, how he could stand and just these words would flow from his lips and continuously.
And I said, damn, I want to be like that.
Then I get to hear King and get to be there.
And the other thing was I liked the way Medgar was always shot, you know.
And then King, he shot, had on a suit that I thought ought to be mad.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean that suit, the way it fit him.
It was double breast and I think it was green kind of thing.
I think he may have been a little hot taller, but I could have, I could have,
I'd have put that suit on even if it was bigger.
You know what I'm saying?
And so I said, call him.
He has to suit any, in the shoes were neat.
And you know, when he said, I'm gonna call him socks.
I mean, I thought, I mean, this to me was really the highlight of everything that I would be in here.
And the thing that I would be in here.
So, Medgar started to work with this white woman named Hazel Brannon Smith,
who ran a little newspaper down in Lexington, Mississippi,
and called a Mississippi Free Press, I think.
And so Medgar would get with us after this paper were delivered to him,
and we would help him distribute them.
And so this is how I'm now beginning to be more involved.
We got this little movement that ain't real off the ground.
And we are really helping Medgar with this, distributed in this newspaper.
And I'm reading about the beatings and the lynchings and things that are having.
And here I get a chance, I learn about Dr. Aaron Henry, up in Clark's tail.
Now, he's prominent in this newspaper, Medgar.
And then I'm reading about Reverend George W. Lee being murdered, you know,
in town called Belzoni, Mississippi.
Most of these places, I'm not familiar with any of them, I just, these are names.
And even the immatil thing is still in the back of my mind that happened out there in the Delta.
And there's some beatings up in Clark's tail that Henry is dealing with in the HCP.
So one afternoon, as I was, we were distributing these newspapers,
the downtown, we were arrested, those of us who were distributing Medgar's paper.
And I call it Medgar's paper because he and his or Brandon Smith was doing the paper,
but Medgar was helping her get the, because she was dealing with some issues
that no other declaring legend, the Jackson Daily News, would not deal with.
And so, in being around Medgar this particular day, I said, Medgar Evers,
how are we going to stop white people from lynching us?
You know, Medgar took a minute or two and he said, bring the guys by my office,
this afternoon, around three o'clock, it's around up all of you.
So several of us met Medgar in his office, the only street up in up stairs then.
And he took this big map out of the state of Mississippi
and drew a circle around the Mississippi Delta
and said, here's how we start with voter registration.
And he talked about how the legislature was apportioned, how the people got to be there,
and how many of them we could possibly send if we got up into the Delta and registered these people.
And it's coming to me about what he is and these people had talked about,
voter registration about, you know, that's what Bill,
and this is now done in Ome about voting and registering.
But then I learned that Lawrence Guyot has now is in the state and he's with SNCC.
And so I don't know Guyot, but then one afternoon, my friends and I was standing on the campus of Jackson State College.
And they were contemplating going to college and I was thinking about this is where I ought to go to college.
But I have not yet gotten my certificate of graduation.
And so, but anyway, we were talking, and this big red fellow walks up to us.
It said, fellas, my name is Lawrence Guyot.
I was SNCC and I'm full of papers as he always had.
And he quips out one of these papers and said, look, y'all get around.
He said, this is a duplication of the application for voter registration.
He said, in a U-Fellows here, 21, he said, but you can help register blacks to vote.
And the vote is going to free us. That's we're going to get free through the vote.
He said, now, I've got headquarters on road street.
So, come by there. Just come by. Y'all coming. And I'll talk to you.
We'll talk about how. He said, there's a guy coming named Bob Moses,
thinking to set up a voter registration project in the Mississippi Delta.
Come by. He went on. We didn't think much about that.
Well, we were really kind of, I lacked the way he approached the this thing, you know,
because the salesman's ship, you know, the way he promoted himself and what he was doing.
See, one of the things about me, I was always interested in these people who could project themselves
and who could speak well, who just had words flow out of them.
And I want to know how to do this. How can I do this?
So, anyway, several days passed. And one day my friend James Jones and I were just goofing off.
And each day we would go around over Jackson State, you know,
because the young teachers are coming for the summer, young kids, girls are coming in to the campus.
And we go down there, stand around and pick at them and get a few phone numbers or something.
But anyway, so we dropped by 714, I believe, Rose Street. Freedom House.
We dropped by there one day and Lawrence Guyot was there along with two or three other white guys and who were people related who were involved somehow in the movement.
And so Lawrence Guyot talked to us and went through this whole thing. He picked up on where Medgar had kind of got us to when he told us this was how he was going to be.
And then Lawrence Guyot said, you got a chance to be right there in it.
I double and die in, I did it in the Delta by now, are they staying with Mr. Lee?
They are in the Delta. I don't know where they are really at this point, but that's where they were.
They had been up with Amzie Moore and worked with him and had worked in Ruleville, Mississippi.
That's why we didn't have much trouble getting into Ruleville, Mississippi because Rev. James Bevel and Amzie Moore had already been there and several and Rev. James Bevel had taken several of the young women from Ruleville, Mississippi to Southern Christian leadership.
Citizenship training over in Dorchester, Georgia. He had taken several of them and they had been over the Amzie Moore train.
And a lady by name of Mary Tucker was one of these people.
I didn't know that it happened before you were on one of these.
Yeah, the Rev. James Bevel had been there. But Rev. James Bevel was constantly coming back in and out of Jackson because he's working for Southern Christian Leadership Conference with Dr. King.
And Diane, I believe she was still with SNCC, or she was, they had gotten married.
But anyway, when each...
I'm going to do one more question.
Diane, what did you think of Diane at the time?
She was pretty.
Yeah, she, you know.
I don't think what mostly I thought about is her involvement here in all of these guys.
And of course, there were several other women, but she was always outspoken.
And usually women had kind of been more in the background.
Most of the women that I knew girls, I knew were more naive about things.
And here she was right up front debating without Brooks and all of these other people.
And she was... she seemed...
She was a pottene in this.
You know what I'm saying?
We didn't have no girl pottene in our effort.
You know, because we considered ourselves to be, I guess, little gangsters.
One of my favorite movie stars was Edwin G. Robinson.
And, you know, George Raft,
And these guys, because they were bad men.
And, you know, the police didn't threaten them.
They didn't feel threatened by the police, you know.
They seemed to be able to function and then do things.
And we didn't think about whether it was right or wrong, but they were in the finds of what things that stood in their way.
And I was always now concerned about things standing in my way.
You know, that's for somehow I can't.
I seem like every space that I had, if a white man wanted that space,
I had to get out of that space and give it to him.
I had to always take a step to the side or step to the back and never step forward.
And so that bothered me.
So if I'm getting involved here and they tell me that this vote is going to get Mr. Chalell from my back,
it's going to get Mr. Charlie in a position where, that if I walked up to him,
two equals of, equals of meeting, you know, that because the mentality had been that white men don't shake a black man's hand.
He don't look a white man in the face when he's talking to him.
And he always assumed a subservient type position or attitude.
When it walked up to him, I got to take my hat off and look down and hold my hat behind me.
You know, and that bugged me. I mean it bothered me.
And so Medgar Evers had said that, get up to the dealt to register these people, blacks outnumber whites.
We could send this number of members to the legislature.
This is how we're going to change things so we're not treated bad.
And this is another we're going to equal the playing field and then heads that talk somewhat about that.
He didn't go into that kind of detail. Medgar Evers didn't go into, Lawrence Guyot goes now into organizing in various communities for voter registration.
And now Chalekal, this is where I meet Chalekal at the Freedom House.
Now Chalekal had come through their own ways down to Texas to write a story about the Freedom Movement.
And Lawrence Guyot had got him here and told him, you know what he was going to do.
And why you can be up front, you can be in it.
You can be a part of it.
And that there's a guy named Bob Moses who's coming through here in a while.
And he is taking, he will take the people who are here ready to go to the delta.
And so, and that's so cops is hanging around there with Lawrence Guyot.
And my friends and I are going back to doing what we were doing and you know, not really thinking maybe none of this is going to happen who knows.
And Jesse is involved in a boycott then Jackson. We're helping him.
And just kind of doing things. And then Lawrence Guyot sends word that Bob is coming on this particular night, which was going to be Saturday night.
August 1962, he's going to come to Freedom House and he's going to take with him the people who Lawrence Guyot have recruited and to the delta.
So myself, James Jones, Chalekal, another student from many of the name Landy McNair is there, may have been some others.
So now, Bob Moses is coming all day long. We are hanging around.
And I'm thinking that, that this guy Bob Moses, since he's been talked about, never about, talking about him, that he's Paul Bunyan type.
He's about 7, 395 pound, base voice, you know. And we all there, counter, having a punch or whatever it is we're having and sandwiches.
And after a while, people are coming in in the door. Then after a while Lawrence Guyot gets up and says, okay, we're going to listen to Bob Moses.
And I'm looking all around because I haven't seen this fella that I'm expecting coming in. I've seen people coming in, you know.
And he says, you got it Bob. And this little fella, coming out of the background out there. And Bob, Bob maybe about 5, 9, 5, 10, somewhere in there.
And certainly not what I was expecting. And so my name is Bob Moses. And then he goes to talking about to move and talking about voter registration and about stuff like that and freedom and all of this kind of stuff.
And now instead of expecting this big tall guy who could seem like his voice would calm the scene as this little fella, little meat like fella who's, but he's saying important things.
He's no, he's the words of, so now I'm catching him, catching on now to him because he's starting to ain't what I expect. I expect him to come with an axe.
Yeah, larger than life. Like the giant in the story of Jack and the Beanstalk.
So you're expecting Bob to be there. Yeah, it's giant. You know, that can speak and things happen. You know, turn the world upside down. And you know, we can on the table and silence in an auditorium of thousands of people.
But then it's the, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's thought pattern and his ability to reach out and say things that touch you and you know, but anyhow.
So we sat around there while and then Guillard and Bob talked and we're headed for Greenwood. This is August, 19, I believe 1962.
And we we we load up in a car car myself landed James Jones and Bob and we're heading for Greenwood, Mississippi. Up in the Mississippi Delta place I'd heard about and you know, it was really anxious to see, you know, I had accidentally been through the Delta ones.
And that was because I was on the Greyhound bus coming from Chicago and took the wrong bus in Memphis instead of taking the bus that travel, how we 51. I'd accidentally got on the bus because it said Jackson is going to Jackson, but it was coming around
through the Delta and it was and I so but I never sold a Delta. This is my opportunity now look like I'm going to be in the Delta and I was anxious, but it was at almost 11 o'clock at night when we arrived in Greenwood and Bob met there with Sam Block and
Sam Block, Levin Brown, maybe Willie Peacock, I'm not sure whether Peacock come in later, but anyway Levin Brown from Jackson, one of my friends who had gone on the Freedom Ride was there with Sam.
See Sam was from Cleveland, Mississippi and he, Amzie Moore was his hero and Bob met Sam when he visited Amzie Moore and Sam was inspired by Bob. Sam was a student at Mississippi Valley State University and he was pissed off because of when they went to Greenwood the way they were treated, black people, you know, kids.
And the town of Greenwood and was segregated and blacks had no rights that white people had to respect. There was no respect to black people and he was a college student when he felt black, you all at least be getting a little bit attention, you know, rather than a cursed out and run out of town.
Sam asked Bob to allow him to set up a voter registration drive in Greenwood, in the floor county and worked in the floor county, Greenwood is in the floor county and to allow him to work down there.
So Bob dropped Sam off in Greenwood one night or something that he was up here in the Delta with Amzie Moore and so Sam had been there and he had finally located, when Sam first went in there, he didn't have no place to stay.
And he slept in old cars in the junkyard for several weeks and then every morning he would appear talking to people in the streets and around in Greenwood and people were afraid of him really because what he represented.
And Sam finally, well he got a house to what he got was a black photographer named Barnes in Greenwood to allow him to set up a SNCC office on the second floor of Barnes studio and so Sam did that.
And when we came up there that night, Sam blocked and Brown and these other guys had already been visited by the Claim, White Citizens Council and run out of that building.
And now the city of, I mean the blacks in Greenwood was really tied up now, they were tied. They wasn't allowed nothing that touched the movement to be in and Barnes were threatened by the White community.
And so that night after we, things, things, when we got into town and we were asking about Sam, people knew he was there and they had been run out of that office and Sam and Levin Brown and whoever else was there with their maven Wazir Peacock, where he, even the black community,
they were deep into the black community and they were here in an area of old houses where a lot of black folks lived.
And Amzie Moore said they've never Booker T. Washington all of the black folks in Greenwood and Greenville and Clarksdale. These were three towns he said that it was impossible to count them because most of them were Booker T. Washington because they got welfare checks or they got food commodities.
That's what the food stamp then. And that, they were functionally anonymous, was Ames's words, that they came out, did whatever they had to do, but you couldn't never find them.
And you didn't know how many of them lived in a house. He said the senses will never Booker T. Washington all of the black folks in these towns because they lived so popped.
I mean, from Highway 49, going east and Highway 82 and the river because the white folks on the north side of the river and over in here all of these blacks, thousands of them.
And that's going to play a role later in the Meredith Mollage, it's a black power. So anyway, after Bob and Sam has talked and everything there and they have found that they have been sleeping in a pool hall that night after the pool hall closed.
This guy who ran the pool hall will allow them since they didn't have nowhere to be to live in to stay in the pool hall, to slip back in after they close up.
So Bob and Sam and talked and everything and then Bob took myself, landed magnair and Charles E. "Charlie" Cobb Jr to Amzie's house.
We hit the highway. Highway 49, east.
So did you show up in Greenwood that night after they went out on the television when they went out the windows?
No, we showed up there a few nights after that. That had happened before we got there and Bob was going up there because, you know, Sam could have left if he wanted.
But Bob offered him an opportunity to get out of there for you know, but Sam was determined to stay.
You know, I think one of the things that kind of tied us all together of the group that Bob was able to get up was this desire to break out of the box.
You know, and Carl Sam was pissed off because of the way he, you know, and but anyway, we went on drove through Ruleville, Mississippi, Mississippi that night on our way to Cleveland.
And as we approached the Ruleville, Mississippi, Bob told us it has occurred to you here and the black folks have to be offered the road in their houses in this community.
Now, it's already midnight, maybe 10, 15 minutes after midnight.
And we're driving a convertible O's mobile and Bob's driving and we're creeping through Ruleville, Mississippi.
Now, I'm looking at any minute, thinking at any minute, some bunny five tight is going to spring out from behind a building and we're going to get arrested and be in jail in this little one-horse town.
And I write about this story on my back in the day, you know, writing a report was important and making a record. Bob always said, you know, make a record.
And I wasn't used to doing a lot of writing. My best paper in college was a D. When I got there. But anyway, I did jot down stuff.
And then things I thought important, I wrote it down. But this particular night, and I'm sitting there on pins and needles,
and I was looking thinking that we were going to wound up in jail in this town. But we made it on through. And the sweetest little sign, I mean the sweetest sign that I ever saw was the sign that Ruleville, Mississippi behind us.
And you know, we were on highway eight headed for Amzie Moore to Cleveland. And when I finally looked back and saw that sign, it's a Ruleville, Mississippi, Mississippi. I felt safe. And so when we finally got to Cleveland to Amzie Moore house at 614 Chrisman Avenue, I was surprised at Amzie Moore house.
You know, in other words, we don't pass, we don't been in Greenwood for a few minutes. And I ain't seen no brick house. This is for black folk. Because I really didn't get around that much. We never got off that little area on our new eye right there kind of little business type area.
You know, and I never got off that. But as we travel on through the community, I didn't never see what I would consider middle class dwellings. But they were valent those days. But all of the blacks had to live together on those days. There were no middle class settlement out there with 15, 20, 30 brick houses and nice cars.
You know, they were there. But they were all all of blacks had to live together. So a school teacher who was a good Sarah and a nice car would be living next door to a shack that's falling down in those days.
So anyway, but when I get to Amzie Moore, we come off the highway. The way we came in, I didn't get to see a lot of Cleveland. And it's after midnight. And in all of a sudden, here we are pulling up in front of this nice brick house. And we're going there to see a black guy. And so we got there bar was up. I mean, Amzie Moore was up and waiting for us.
And we go in and nice living room and dining table and kitchen and everything is here. And Bob and Amzie Moore talked all night. I don't ever remember them going to bed. But Amzie Moore, before we fell asleep, told us kind of the history of his life and involvement after the war.
And what he in the NAACP there and what he had been doing and and and Amzie Moore operated a business there and nice business. Cafe and gas station and the troubles that he had been having getting money and how he all over Baker had helped him by setting him up with Tri-State Bank of Memphis.
And because the banks wouldn't make him alone, they had tried to fire him from his job at the post office. And because he was a federal employee, he would keep his job. And that he had managed to function kind of anonymously.
Because what he did was Amzie Moore organized in NAACP there and he put on his overalls and old clothes and old hat and go out onto the plantations and to register people. Then he had a choir. And he would take his choir on a Sunday to the church in the very surrounding community. And while they are singing and people are shouting Amzie Moore right in NAACP memberships.
And the little girl, ladies and things in there helping him right by and they passing up the little envelopes with the with the with the fee in them and for the NAACP. And next morning, Sunday morning, Bob Moses wakes us up. So let's go. We didn't know what was going and said we were going to church.
I'm trying to figure out, no, I'm not a church going person. Not very much now. But then at night at all. And we're going to church. And so we load up in Bob's car and Amzie Moore car. And I learned that we're going to Ruleville, Mississippi.
She is doing them glad it's daylight. And so we go to Ruleville, Mississippi and we drive through the way we came in and go to a little church right at the edge of the community of Ruleville, Mississippi called Mount Galilee Baptist Church. That was the name of the church.
And it is here that Bob and Amzie Moore had set up for us to meet the black leadership in Ruleville, Mississippi who had requested, SNCC organizers to help them set up and care out their voter registration drive to help get likes registered.
We, well, Bob and Ams, it brought us to Mount Galilee Baptist Church church and the service was taken place there. And we stayed for the service. And then after the service was over, Bob introduced us to Mr. Joe McDonald, his wife Rebecca, George Jordan, Miles Foster.
These are local community people, Jack Sison and his wife Mary Tucker. These are people who want them to register the vote. Rev. James Bevel have been through there. And he's talked with him about voter registration and about getting registered sunflower county as a county where 70% of the population is black.
Each one of the little six small communities and that incorporated and they have white, they have white mayors, white aldermen.
Everything is white, constable, justices of the peace, all the white people and yet blacks are 70% of the whole county.
And they had very few of any people registered the vote because of the violence and intimidation and the murder of Teal and that kind of forced, they were forced to run the NAACP out of the county.
And the most often people who received mail from the NAACP turned that mail over to the white citizens council. So what they wanted was to bring in the SNCC people who could organize around, you know, without the fear of taking the steps to help them get registered the vote.
They had promised them SNCC people. See Bob and Amzie Moore had met a year or so earlier. And at that time when Bob wanted to talk about voter registration, SNCC was not ready.
SNCC was into demonstrations and so rather than selling in the Delta in the early day of SNCC, they went to Macon, where they could, they started demonstrations and kids walked out of school and a lot of pressure was put on the local people there.
And so Bob and SNCC had to get out. And so then moved into Jackson and then now this project is developing in the Delta. So Mt. Galilee Baptist Church, and Mt. Galilee Baptist Church that day Bob and Amzie Moore assigned us to live in the home of Joe McDonald and his wife.
They had agreed to take and take us SNCC people in all three of us landed, child and myself to take us in and to assist us to, you know, their ability to get registered to vote.
So they took us home that evening after that service. Bob and Amzie Moore, this is one of the things that I always kind of tease people about.
He said, well, you know Bob, he just brought us through there and dropped us off and said, sink us sweet. So, you know, and so he left us there and next morning after I was first night there, Bob, you know, child and myself and landing.
I walked out into the community. I believe, I was not if I make no mistake, child was straightening it out. He's written a lot of this.
And we walked out into the community, familiarize ourselves with the community. And after we had gone a few blocks, this car, white car, pulls alongside of us.
And this little white man steps out and said, you need us getting the car. And I said, for what? Because this 38 says it.
And we looked at one another and got in the car. And we were taken to the city hall in Ouvia. And told us to take seats. We took seats. The mayor went back in the back room and made some phone calls. And then he came back. And he said, if I were you niggas, I would go back to New York.
I get out of here now. If you don't, something bad is going to happen to you. And I said, we're not from New York. I'm from Jackson, Mississippi.
So, he went and made some phone calls and then he came back and said, you niggas can go. And so just as we were leaving, now, when we were arrested,
the black folks who were out on the porch looking in everything were who were not aware of what was happening until they saw the mayor. And so I was getting the car. And then they disappeared.
You know, they went in and he and you could see him peeping out of the windows from around the corner of the house or under the house or whatever.
There was kids. Nobody was anyway. Well, anyway, the mayor told this guy told us to get in the car. We didn't know who he was.
He's a white man with a gun. And so he drove us off and carried us to the city hall.
And now we're getting when he finally tells us we can leave. I said, you're not going to carry us back to where you got us. And he said, no, hell no.
I said, now, you don't want you told us you didn't want no trouble. You're in this world. I said, now, you're going to allow three strange black kids to be walking around the community lost.
Because we don't know how to get back to where he's a get your ass in the car. But now a part of this to me and I believe to child and land.
Certainly the main is that these now we're here to register blacks and to help them overcome the fear. And now we if he took us back to where we were, where these people could see we're still alive.
Then that's going to happen. Why didn't we get killed? Why couldn't he run us out of town? Why are we allowed to come back?
See, that's what was in my mind. And it worked. He carried us back to right where he had picked us up and put us out.
Now these blacks who saw his car come back were sitting all out at first. They disappear again. And then when we get out of the car and he pulls away, then they hit it. They're back out.
And a young guy by the name of Laffeyette Sonny was one of the kids who walked out to where we were. And he said, man, I thought y'all was gone. That's a go.
He said, yeah, man, we thought y'all was going to be thrown in the river that y'all was sure to die. We were going to read about you and hear about y'all.
What happened? What happened?
And so we told him who we were, what we were doing. And he said, we're going to have to work this community. We're going to have to meet people.
And he said, well, I'll walk with y'all and show you people. So that's what he did. He walked around the community and introduced us to those who would allow us to talk to them.
And certainly young people, you know, he was a graduate, a recent graduate, a Ruleville High School. And so he knew a bunch of folk and people knew him.
And so we walked around all of that rest of that evening. And there was a mass meeting being held at Williams Chapel M.B. Church in Ruleville, Mississippi of that evening.
So that evening we went to the meeting and he came with us. And so at that mass meeting we talked about taking people down the register of vote.
And we wanted to take a group down right away so we could get the feel of it. And so that night five people agreed to go down to register the vote.
And this was on a Monday we were going to take a group down that Wednesday. And so they were to meet at the church at eight o'clock in the morning.
And so at eight o'clock on the Wednesday morning we came to the church and two old ladies, two or three old ladies of the five, only three people met us that thing.
I knew it wasn't more. And Irene Johnson, who was one of the local ladies that are involved in the movement, had her son to drive.
It was decided that I would be the first person to go with a group down there. Child in Landon would stay in the community and opera and canvas and continue to do things, be present.
And so I went out in the car and we took the two old ladies, they were in the back and Tommy Johnson, drove us to Indianola, Mississippi.
Now in one of the papers that I wrote, I described that trip to Indianola, Mississippi. And I also talk about the fear that was in mean as we drove up to the statue at the courthouse.
And these, and it was my intention to lead these ladies into the courthouse. But now when we moved parked in front of the courthouse, when I knew anything, they were already out of the car.
And they were walking up to the courthouse. So here I come behind them and really looking for some chairs, debateers, some cooklucks, clean members, some white citizen, councilperson to meet us or to come and with baseball bats or some, you know, and I'm hesitant.
And these ladies are walking up there and they're going up to step into the courthouse. I still have made it to the door. And then they went in. And just as I walked into the door, they were coming back because the office was closed.
They couldn't get into the courthouse. So here I stand in this building. And I could see a sign that says "Sheriffs office, colored interest, water fountain, colored, little dingy thing off there to the color.
And looking around, there wasn't a single black face in the courthouse other than a janitor who approached the came out. And he seemed to be glad that we could get on away from that.
He didn't say nothing and he just kind of looked frightened. And he didn't know how well it was too. But now, as I walk out of the courthouse, these ladies are walking down the walk back to the courthouse.
So I kind of stopped and looked back at the courthouse and I thought about Reverend George W. Lee, about Emmett Till, you know, Mack Charles Parker, these people who had been lynched, killed by whites.
And Reverend George W. Lee had been killed about voter registration, about not taking his name off of the book and stop encouraging other people. And here I am here in a little town all along the jail houses right across the street. You could see the bars up there.
There's a bowler running along the bowler there, you know, and it looked like something out of the legend of Sleepy Halle, you know. And I'm thinking about as we get into the car and I said to myself, I said, damn, I got to grow up.
I'm going to be making this trip numerous other times, perhaps. You know, and I perhaps was whether or not I was going to stay in the Delta now. You see what I'm saying? Now am I going to stay up here? And if I'm going to stay here, I've got to be able to not be frightened myself.
So I said to my friends and I mentioned it in something I wrote about growing up there becoming a man. You know, I was a boy. And so now I'm thrown into this situation here. And I thought about, I'm Bob, Bob was sitting in this and we didn't, we came in with eyes open.
But we didn't realize what these people here knew and that was fear. And you don't see no value. But you know, they're there. You know, this is the seat of power.
How do you think those ladies were able to just walk right up like that?
You know, and this is what if you look at this period, these are people who were born in the 30s and the 40s, you know, made the sun back into the 20s.
And they had great hope of seeing things different, some things change. And they had, in a sense, changed because they had came up on a plantation.
They knew about the plantation, the forest and the power and the authority of this guy over their lives. And that the legal system protected them, you know, these owners.
And so their hope was that they would see enough change that their children, you know, wouldn't have to live like they did.
And so the guy asked me one day, he said, why did the blacks go and register in spite of this fear? And it had to do with their wanton to get out of the box.
I tell you, it was really, this was a transformative moment for me.
What am I going to do? What am I going to tell Charlie and Landy when I go back back and tell them that I'm going back to Jackson?
What am I going to say to Maddie who said, this is the way we stopped Mr. Charlie from lynching us.
And I got up there and thought about my own lynching. I hadn't thought about, you know, my lynching. And so all the way back, I'm thinking.
I'm thinking. They didn't get to take the test. No. But now these ladies came back again and again. You know, if you you check the records for that period, 1962, that August through thousands of black people from the delta from that area because their own the population of Ruleville, Mississippi wasn't even 2000 at that time.
So, so almost every adult person in Ruleville, Mississippi had one time or another during that period went to the courthouse and some of them's name appeared every week in the paper because they had to publish the names were published in the newspaper of those people who made application to register the vote.
But if when I got back to Ruleville, Mississippi and was talking to Charlie and Landy about this, what I think sold me on the idea of really staying was that 10 days after well several days after that, we held another mass meeting.
This meeting Miss Mary took on them brought in folks from the plantation. Now, friend in Lou Hamer is one of these people, but I don't know her at this time. See, I don't know her.
So, she is raised as her hand as one of the people in this next group to go down the register to vote. So, we had about 20 some people who said that they would go.
And so, as a result, Amzie Moore and Bavar and Rev. James Bevel rented a bus from a guy in Cleveland, Mississippi, who hauled sharecroppers to work, I mean a labor to the field and each year took that bus load of people from the Delta to Florida to pick fruit and to make money over the summer between the harvest and season.
So, on that day that we got August 31st now, remember we started out August the 19th. August 31st, 1960 to a bus of 18 people included in this bus was Fannie Lou Hamer.
And we took that bus to Indianola, with this group of people on it to register to vote. And this time, Bob and James Forman and a bunch of the SNCC people met us at the courthouse.
I was on the bus with this group. I don't know Fannie Lou Hamer, and I don't even know her at all because I was not at the meeting the night this next meeting was here. I had gone somewhere Jackson or was in Greenville somewhere on that night.
So, that morning was I was to be one of the ones to ride on the bus with the group. I think maybe Charlie was on that bus or landed. Somebody that was...
I think Charlie wrote it.
I think he said that.
Okay, well, Charlie wrote these stories. And he wrote them like, my slave, what I saw, what took place.
But anyhow, when we got there Indianola, Mississippi, the people got off and went in, this little lady, stocked her lady, led the group on up there to the courthouse there.
And they went in and they took the litter and said, first time now that they get the chance to take the test, the man was there.
He probably knew we were coming because the word had been out and around. He obviously knew.
So he probably told him, don't call no problem. You let the niggas in and you let them make the applications because they ain't going to get registered no way.
And so anyhow, they had all taken the test and got ready to go. The police, the police, stocked the bus and arrested the driver of the bus.
And now on this bus, these 18 people, and me, because I think at this point, Charlie joined Bob and the others when they left and went to, where another, one of the things was, Charlie was planning the right.
So he never planned to be a stationed organizer in the community. But anyway, he stayed around in the Delta here a while.
But they took the driver back to the city hall and charged him with driving the bus, the color of a school bus. It was too much yellow in the bus.
Now here this man has been driving this bus, hauling people to all of the plantations around that would hire him and hire these people. And then he had taken this bus all the way to Florida and back, numerous times.
Now all of a sudden on this particular day, it's too yellow. Okay, $30 was the fire. Now while they were away, the bus parked out on the highway,
he had to hit the road. We owned that bus and white man in trucks with guns, a drive and buy and yell and insults and niggas, you're all going to get killed, niggas go home, you're going to be voting, we're going to have no niggas voting.
And that time, so the people on the bus were three on their list. And at this point, I didn't see how they, I didn't think they were going to shoot us up.
I thought maybe they might run us off of the road when we got started. Now I'm trying to, but as the people were uneasy, then this, this singing.
Paul and Sallie, Mount Egypt had no money to go there, and somebody says, that's insane. That's funny, look. Now this is my first hearing of all.
So now the driver come, we proceed on back to ruralville with these trucks and even me and following us and yelling and passing in front of us. And I'm thinking they're going to run us off of the road because I felt like that would be an easy way
to put them to get away with this is that we drive a ran off of the road and it was not somebody's fault. But we made it to ruralville and the people got off and went home.
So some of these riders, these men followed the bus around to see where these people were getting put off at the houses.
But then Fannie Lou Hamer got off and was taken out to W.D. Marlow Plantation where she and her husband and two daughters, two adopted daughters, Leo.
Miss Hamer got there and went in the home, getting ready to take our bath and everything. The boss man or the plantation drove up in front of the house and said,
Pap" Hamer, did you tell Fannie Lou that I wanted to see her? And he said, yes, I did. And so Miss Hamer heard out there and she walked out on the porch and said, here I am, W.D. Marlow Plantation.
And he said, Fannie Lou, you've been over there trying to register the vote. He said, we're not ready for that. And either you go back to Indianola with draw your application to register the vote, or you got to leave my plate, flat edge.
So that was Miss Hamer said she thought about it and said, W.D. Marlow Plantation, I didn't go for you. I went for myself.
I thought that you think about that. You know, here this woman, black, challenge in this meeting, three of them. And I said, shit, look at this. Now, what happened, they were, they talked it over her family and said, okay.
We're going to, you go, Fannie Lou. And we'll stay here, bringing the crop. They were sharecroppers and they owed the man a crop. And if they had left without bringing in the crop, then he had a legal reason to charge them or to, you know, have them arrested or sued them or whatever to get his money to get his share of the crop.
Okay. So Miss Hamer being the woman that she was and trying to be fan just left them there and called her right with one of her neighbors from the next plantation into Ruleville, Mississippi to the latest house that got her in for a married Tucker, to the married Tucker's house.
And Tucker told her, said, you could stay with me as long as you want her. Okay. Now, ten nights later, night riders rolled through the Ruleville, Mississippi community, shot up the community, shot into the house where we were staying at the McDonalds', shot into Sizzle's house, shot into married Tucker's house where Fannie Lou is staying.
And two students at Jackson State College who were visiting their relatives at the Sizzles were shot. And of course, they didn't die. But then the mayor of Ruleville, Mississippi, that next day, went to Joe McDonald house where we were living.
Joe McDonald, where child in the rest of us were living, and took his gun. And he told him he was taking it for his protection. So we were in green, we had been in green with that all that day, meeting and trying to see where we were, get planned for what our next moves and everything's going to be.
So when we came home that evening, Joe McDonald told us that he had been visited by the mayor, and that the mayor had taken his gun. And he said, hey, man, I don't know right to take your gun. You got to write to have a gun to protect yourself and your family and your home. And Joe said, show now.
So you got a government book, history books, you know, McDonald's son had just graduated from high school with Lafayette Surney. And he said, yeah, I got one. So his wife went and got the history book and brought it back and cops opened it to the back where they had the Constitution.
And he said, you're a Constitution and told him, second amendment here gives you that right to, he said, show now.
He said, yeah, said, fold that page down. So child, fold the page down.
Next month, every morning, before we left, we would meet with the McDonalds, have coffee and tell them kind of what our day was going to be like what we'd be doing.
Because after all, we were there at their request and we reported to them, to this group. And so Mr. and and and, and.
And he brought Joe wasn't at the table. I mean, you know, Charlie said, Charlie was talking to some man. He was conspicuously absent. I mean, because brother Joe was six feet tall, dark, handsome guy, you know, and he wasn't at the table.
And so Mr. Mr. Mr. and he was like, no, I have brought Joe. He said, he went to the city hall. We didn't think nothing about it. We kept on getting ready to go out for the day.
And because light beer, gas beer, whatever you have to do, go to go transact that business at the corner house.
And just as we started to walk out the door, Joe McDonald truck pulled up in front of his house. He had a fence around his house, he pulled up in front of the house.
Joe steps out, holding his gun.
Because he knew that his neighbors knew that the man had come and taken his gun. And they never expected him to see the gun again.
You know, and really, they never thought and really if Joe had told us tonight before we were going to do that, we would have wanted to go with him.
Or we would have told him to wait and let the lawyers get there. You see what I'm saying? But Joe told us, what brought Joe? What happened?
He said, well, I went down to the city hall and I told the man, I come to get my gun.
Look, now here I am. The court house scene with these old ladies and the bus ride, Fannie Lou Hamer standing up to this man.
So Joe said, he told the man said, I come to get my gun. The man said, he said, the man told him, say, tight hair nigger, you are going to get killed.
You get them boys out of your house. If you don't get them boys out of your house, something bad is going to happen.
And he said, he just stood there looking at the man.
The man was a little fellow. You about my height, a male, a child's girl. Now, and we had learned he's child's girl by Lafayette Surney had told us.
We didn't know who he was when he first picked us up. But Lafayette Surney had told us about it. Told us a lot about it.
But anyway, he said, the man, he stood there and the man stood there.
And he's looking at the man. So the man is looking up at him. Here's this black guy.
Can't even read and write. He said, the man standing there looking at him like he could bite his head off.
And first time Joe said, first time he ever, he ever looked a white man in the face.
Talked to him, defied him. And Joe said, the man said, well, you get them boys out of your house.
And Joe said, I come to get my gun. Said the man I said, look at that man. And he said, why, what you mean?
He come to get your gun. He said, do I have a right to have a gun? The man I said, no.
He took this book on from up his own. He made it out to that page. The man I looked at it.
And said, nigga, you don't get killed. You and the boys. You got to get them boys out of here.
When older and the corner got his gun, gave it to him to let him get out of there.
So now Joe is back home with his gun. He'll hide. And his neighbors all come out.
Joe, what happened? What happened? And he's telling them.
And so we had been having maybe 20, maybe sometime 30 people at the mass meeting.
That next meeting, the church was overflowing. And you know who was the speaker?
Joe, don't. Brother Joe, from the end of the year, we limited our involvement in the rules of the year.
We moved here because now we've got Joe. Joe and these ladies are meeting citizenship classes.
So we move on to Indianola, Mississippi and to town of sunflower and Greenville. And back there, we still maintain our place there.
But we moved around more now because we got Rovia moving. I read Johnson and these people are canvassing.
So first of all, I'm still Booker T. Washington, I'm puzzled here about this fear that these people have.
But they are willing to walk out there. You see, especially now because of what they now know.
You see what I'm saying? In other words, Joe didn't know he had that right.
These people have seen the man dominate their lives. And there was nothing they could do about it.
So what we've done come and kind of gave them a little lift in the spirit.
You know, stuff they wanted to do, wanted to say what were afraid.
We now can absorb and we're between them and the man.
So, and then I thought about, we thought about it and I'm sure child in New Estonia, Ella Baker.
Go to the people who have the lease, motivate them, stimulate them, educate them to the best of your ability.
And then get out of their way. Get out of their way. And that's what we did.
I met Ella Baker at a SNCC conference. I had seen several times before, but I only met her at Biloxi, on the Gulf Coast when we had the meeting to decide for the summer project.
And that's when I actually met her. I had never, I had seen this little lady. I didn't know who she was.
You know, and they had talked, she had talked and stopped by them and arrested the people. She had been introduced to us.
But I didn't see her significance other than a guidance person, you know, a counselor, because she always spoke.
So, we get debating and get to an impasse of some mortgage and then she would come in and logically get us back on the right track and stuff like that.
So, but I only met her when we went to Baloxy, Gulf for whatever was on the Gulf Coast, Pascagoula, somewhere around there, to get ready for the summer project.
And we're Bob, they'd be late on the table. But so, following her teaching is what we got from Baloxy and Forman, and Beveling these people.
She taught them, and they had taught her. And then I read a little bit about her and about this and heard Ruleville, Mississippi Dars Smith and Nick talk about her, they had a mind.
And I was always kind of interested in knowing these important folk and how they did things, how they reasoned stuff and how they were able to get us back on track, you know, to say those words that would keep things moving.
Even from way back in Madgum, I'm interested in this as I'm learning. See, because this, I'm, now what really helped me really decide to stay in the Delta was the Fannie Lou Hamer connection here, you know. She's kicked out of her home.
She leaves her family on the plantation. She moves, comes into, into rural, the place is shot up, people are wounded, nothing is done about this. And she's still that person who is out there, study moving.
The man didn't make her go back and withdraw her application because she didn't want to. And she had found, she'd been wanting to leave the plantation all of her life. She was born on the plantation. Her mother was a, her mother plantation, her great grandmother was a slave. And all her life she had seen, this man.
And his power. And what has happened is, SNCC has come in him, given her the motivation to challenge me. God, okay. Then after the place was shot up, she still don't go back and withdraw her application. Her family is still on the plantation.
And then, Bob Moses assigns me to go and locate this woman, Fannie Lou Hamer, who had gone down the register, went through this place with shot up, and who was the first person of the group that she went down with to raise her hand to go register the vote.
Okay, now I get the assignment, I go looking for Fannie Lou Hamer because now she's no longer living with Ms. Tucker. She's gone to live with relatives up in Tallahatchie County.
So I find out where Tallahatchie County is, it's the wrecking city. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm really lost up here. I only know my way to the courthouse and to him's this house and the green wood at this time, you know what I'm saying.
So anyway, ask people about where to go and they tell me they give me direction. And you know, black folks, you've got direction from black folks, you got lost.
But, yeah, yeah, take a ride up there, a stoke up on top of the hill that was there 20 years ago and they didn't throw it down there.
And you'll find a big puck on tree, 20 miles down the road down and they don't plow that up and plan and cut.
And so anyway, and so I take off driving a convertible 1957 Chevrolet car with a hands-Booker T. Washington tag on it, belonging to Dave Dennis.
And so here I am driving up and hunting for the place and got lost and got off on a road listening to these people and got stuck in the mud.
I got the car off the road because I'm not used to driving on gravel. I'm used to driving on highway pavement. I grew up in Jackson, Mississippi, I ain't used to this.
But, and a white farmer come back, sees me over there in the ditch and says, boy, what's he going to done?
And I told him that I'm not used to driving up here in the Delta and he said, yeah, I see you from Hinds County. What are you doing way up here?
I said, I'm up here visiting my relatives. I go to school down in Jackson and I'm up here to visit my relatives and I just got lost.
He said, well, boy, you get in the car and he, I'm going to get you out. So he hooks the winch thing to the car, pull me out.
I thank him and he said, no, you stay out of ditches now. I said, yes, sir.
So I go home and finally cross highway 49 and driving back up to the highway there and I ran into these black guys sitting at a little store.
I really reluctant to ask them because I don't want to be lost no more. But I go over there and ask them and I'm about where the people,
and I tell them that I'm a fan of those relatives who told me up in Tallahassee and a little town called Cassilla. And I'm there and I tell these guys what I'm looking for.
Oh, yeah, I know fan of them. They call her Hill. I know him. I said, you do this, yeah. You see that house up there? He said, that's what you're fine.
I'm happy to know what now. I've been lost and taken all day long. It's in the evening now and to get right here and then they fall from where I was.
But it's the way I had gone all around listening to people. So now I'm up there. I go up there. It's been raining, pouring down and it starts back to raining as I'm headed down to the house.
And when I get there up there, it's a hill and there's a plantation shack at the hill, top of the hill. I get out and I don't want to walk in the mud really because again, I'm from used to walking on concrete streets and everything.
But my mission is to get me the same up. Get up to Tougaloo College in Jackson. So I walk on up the hill and I get up there and it's a shack.
And if you've seen these plantation type houses, some of them have got a big open space in the middle with rooms on the side of it.
It's a big open lock car door and it opens on the back end of the front but there are rooms off to each side. And I get up there and now it's pouring down.
And I knock on the door and a voice inside said, who is it? And I said, my name is Charles McLeod and I'm looking for Fannie Lou Hamer. The voice says, come in.
So I go in to the open the door and sitting right in front of me is this Wayne back chair, a big chair and a stone, wood burning stone, red hot.
And this person gets up out of the seat and says, I'm Fannie Lou Hamer. And I'm happy now. I have spent all day long looking for this little lady and I've found and I tell her that Bob Moses told me to come locate you and bring you to Tougaloo College today.
She says, have a seat. I'll be right with you. You understand? Now think about that. She don't even know me from Adam's house. What am I robber, murderer, burglar, whatever the hell I am. She says, have a seat. I'll be right with you.
And she goes in there and packs up a little bag and everything. Comes back. We go down the hill to that car, get in the car and she talk all the way to Tougaloo College.
About her life. She's just talking about her life, her life on the plantation and all the kinds of things that she's been doing and how she wanted to get, wanted to get away from here, to get away and about how she had tried and her family had tried to get away, wanted to be stopped by plantation people, white, white man on the plantation, kill all, kill their mule and broke up there.
And they broke up there, plow and pause and stop the pigs and stuff that they were going to use to make enough money to rent their own land, to grow a crop.
And so she talked to all the way to Tougaloo College and told me about her life. I don't know if I ever said very much because there was no in between and I'm glad now to be getting out from up there.
And I'm headed for Jackson. You understand? I'm not sure what I'm going to do when I get to Jackson. I don't know what Bob never got up because he just said, bring him to Tougaloo College.
Bob had a way of just asking you to do things. He always asked. He never demanded it. And you just do him because he said it because you really want to do it.
And I'm thinking about whether or not when I get to Jackson, well I'm going back up there not doing something.
So we get to Tougaloo College and find out that this is a rendezvous point for people from McComb, and South to meet with those of us in the Delta and travel to from there, from Tougaloo College to Nashville, Tennessee to a SNCC conference.
So now when I learn about that, now I've got something else to think about because we're going to Fisk University. You see what I'm saying? To a college.
And so now I'm interested in now I'm interested in this because here's another learning opportunity for me. We're going away from Mississippi to Tennessee.
And so that night we load up in the car. Hollis Watkins and I meet Hollis Watkins. I never met Hollis Watkins, Dorie Ladner and Joyce Ladner and Curtis Hayes and Victoria Gray Adams. And you know I meet all of these people that Bob have got coming up to get to Nashville.
So we load up in a car and several cars take off in Nashville and Fannie Lou Hamer, Hamers in the car with you know strange thing about this when now I was around 20 right at 20, I would be 20 soon because I registered to vote shortly after I was in the Delta.
So I believe I was around 20 and going to be 21 you know at that December. So anyway we never, Fannie Lou Hamer was 44 years old. And you know nobody in that car or at the SNCC conference questioned her age.
You know I didn't even know how her little hammer was and really gave an in thought until you know she had been in the movement for months or maybe a year or more.
Everybody just this is Miss Hamer. She was dubbed Miss Hamer and that was what stuck with she was till the day she died. That's what she still is today. Miss Hamer. To a SNCC people. And so but anyhow we took off in Nashville had problems with tires tore up on the old car.
Managed to get another tire and we made it on to Nashville because we ran off of the road late at night. We were blessed and not yet keel and door you out of here door tell that story.
We went off of the road and we were basically sleep you know and the guy Landy McNair was driving the car and he said after we finally went off I was you know feel and backup on the highway and run going backwards down the highway in the car.
And then they say what happened he says I guess I went to sleep.
But I look at so I think Miss Hamer told him to get out mother wheel and I'm not sure I think he the child or Hollis started to drive and we got to Nashville at and then the next night.
The conference Nick conference this is where Fannie Lou Hamers discovered you know she had a during the SNCC meeting.
And then I was like a SNCC people you know get up and go to testify and about where you know this and then when Miss Hamer came on and went to talking about the things her life in song singing and then moving from that over into biblical Shadrach, Meshach and then the Daniel in the lions' den and Paul and Silas in jail.
And then they were all just kind of how she could mix that all in and everybody's in their spell by you know because she have captured this conference of all of these big people James Forman and Bob and Joe McDonald and Julian Bond and all of these folks at that meeting and when the meeting broke up.
James Rev. James Bevel myself.
Emma Bale James Jones and Lafayette Surnick came back to the Delta and but Mrs. Hamer they took Mrs. Hamer on a whirlwind tour of Northeastern universities and colleges.
Right from that meeting right from that meeting and I don't see her again until late in December.
This conference was in I believe was either in October or November right at the end of October.
You was a particular thanks.
Okay and November is in November okay and but I don't see her again until late in December and by this time her family have moved into
the room and paid off that dead they're moving the room so.
Did Mrs. Hamer and the other people up in the room they started to register and all of this happened. Did they ever express any hesitation?
You know this they got more involved and it invigorated the movement because now the people they were running it really.
In other words I dropped through there, get them stuff that they needed printed up I get it to Greenville or where
they needed to go and now I'm writing the reports.
Charlie has moved on to another because Charlie was in charge of writing the reports.
Landy and I would sit down with him and we would go but now I'm in charge of writing the reports I got the town.
Now this my project landed have moved on and so I'm now there and but these people kept me going.
I never thought about going back to Jackson now because now I'm kind of in the middle.
There's a song or blues song. The guy said that he found himself in the middle of a big fish fry.
He said I was writing the mill of a big fish fry.
I'm writing the mill of all of these people.
Fannie Lou over there Joe Magdalene, Irene Johnson and all of these folk, these young people I'd met and all these young good looking women
and things who are now coming to the project and they bringing me lunch and there's an old white lady and there's a black lady there in town.
There was a freight of us. We wouldn't even let us come to her place and she's now inviting me to come and sit inside the door while she said on the porch to talk to me.
She had this good baloney in her little old show and she cut me a big slice of baloney and a red drink and I would talk and she would tell me about what's going on.
So now I'm the one.
So I wrote levels. I remember there's a guy named Nick Barnes.
He had got this honorable discharge from the Army and he told me his story and I sit down and wrote it up and sit his letter and you know he received the honorable discharge.
So now we're empowering folk. You know what I'm saying? See we had empowered Joe McDonald and all of these people here who wanted to get out of this situation, this box.
They wanted to overcome this fear and we had helped them by bringing in the Justice Department even though they didn't do much.
We were bringing in the FBI and they weren't doing nothing but these people and the mayor of the town is backing off of them.
See the last battle we had with him was when the insurance company counsels the insurance on the church on William Chapel and the mayor stopped allowing, started making them pay a water bill and they had been getting free water.
And the, you see the insurance company and the the mortgage hold on the church, you know.
So all of this pressure is now coming on them and the mayor told them that all they had to do was get a run us out of town.
He said run these boys out of town and you won't have this trouble. The church board met you know to consider the question.
Joe McDonald and these people, we ain't running these boys nowhere. I said she.
If I went back to Jackson, what would I be doing?
I ought to go back there and go to college because now I see the need you know.
I went down to Valestay one day when I was goofing off and learned about the equivalents exam and went back two days later and took it past it.
Got. Yeah. And so now we up to a meeting in Baloxie to talk about freedom sum.
And then once we got there talked about that.
Okay. We're back. Yeah. I was against it because we had been working. We had registered very few voters, almost no voters had come out of our effort.
But we had brought these communities to a point where Greenwood, Greenville, Cleveland, Clarksdale, all these places where we've been working.
We had established SNCC in a sense. We didn't organize SNCC chapters. We helped them put together local organizations where none existed and we helped them to stimulate the NAACP and to help pull together meetings consistent in these various communities.
And we had helped them kind of get over Mr. Charlie dominating their lives because the white man, his wife and children were more than they were.
And they had to treat these children like they treated a man. And so we failed that idea. And I think Charlie, this is kind of someone who had a child that said, well, that we're going to bring white people into the communities.
And put them in people's home. And they are going to be the blacks are going to be again dominating. They're now going to be led by the people we, the white folks we brought in.
We have kind of pushed Mr. Charlie back off of them a little bit. And he was allowing them to breathe a little better because we had had boycott in the rural village and shut the town down in a period in here.
When Fannie Lou Hamer got back to rural village, we conducted a boycott. We hauled people to Cleveland to spend their money. And we boycott the rural village and we had some new movement over in the town of Sunflower.
And so this, I said that this would all be lost. But just the opposite happened. You know, we brought these kids. We had the training in Oxford.
And Ohio and brought these kids down while they were there. So on a good man and training was killed. Bob came before him and offered him a chance to chicken out.
Said, you know, nobody did. I don't think nobody left from Oxford. The kids all came. We brought them into the Delta.
I met Tracy Sugarman there, but I hadn't, I had lived with him earlier. See, SNCC had sent several of us north to New York for rest and relaxation.
And they had sent us to these big, right rich white folks out in Connecticut, Tracy Sugarman. Excuse me. And I was assigned to Tracy Sugarman.
And so we had already met with friends and Tracy Sugarman about this coming together. And he came to the conference there to the training session.
And I met him there. He said, I said, Tracy, what are you doing here? You know, because all these other people were college kids.
You know, from, yeah. And I, yeah, he's old guy. And he said, I was thinking about going south. I said, you don't have to think no more. You with me, you can come to my project.
You know, and he told me then about how he had this contract to do these drawings of the movement to, to, to, to portrait the movement in picture.
And, and I took welcome him. He came on my project and then was very helpful. He brought a car.
You know, the strange thing was Nick didn't have a lot of transportation. A lot of, and he, but the car he brought was a car he ran 50, 1950, 64, Sherley, Impala, Canary Yellow.
And we were trying to be as inconspicuous as possible always, you know, and yet we had it, but hey, that's okay. It ran and it was new. And he was willing to drive it.
And, and to be involved here. And we placed these blacks, for instance, we placed Tracy in the home of Rennie Williams at her granddaughter and her husband.
They didn't have running water in the house. They didn't have toilet facilities in the house. Now here's Tracy coming from Tracy Sugarman, illustrated artists and writers.
You know, up a middle class coming to, and we placed him there. And all of these other kids that came from other places came from, Linda Davis's dad.
And one of the young white girls that came was a tax accountant, big time tax accountant up in New York, lawyer and tax accountant.
And he had a congressman from, from, had a congressman son on, from California.
And he, on this, on my project there. And he was in law school. He was, Edwards, his, that, that was Don Edwards. And he was Len Edwards.
And he brought a car on to the project. And they all brought up my communication specialists from up in, way up in Minnesota.
And, and, and, and all of these kids coming. It was my feeling in the early days that they were dominating.
These people that they were coming to live with were sharecroppers, shoe shine boys, you know, God is collectors, laborers, you know, low paid laborers,
poverty stricken, and that's it's shit. They all come in and, and, and undo everything we've done, not to put these, these people are going to be in,
and, and, and, and, and, and undo everything we've done, not to put these, these people are going to be, and, except serving them.
You know, well, some interesting things happen.
Tracey Sugarman, then he went to live with the, the Williams. One morning, and I was living with Amzie Moore. Now, I, I didn't live in Ruleville, Mississippi on the moon.
Now, I'm living in, in Amzie Moore's house in Cleveland, and, and working in the Delta. I'm responsible for a second congressional district now.
But, one morning as I came to Ruleville, Mississippi, cut around through town, I see traces, canary yellow car, sitting up at a grocery store, downtown Ruleville, Mississippi.
I said, well, okay, we had had our, our discussions and things was that these kids were to not join, you know, not go off by themselves, and, and, to be as inconspicuous as possible, stay in the black within the black community until we had reasons to go out.
And I look and see traces, call over there, at the, at the supermarket. And then, I look and see traces coming out of the store with bags in his arm,
really William and this little girl, this little, this William, and this little, a little granddaughter, coming out of the store with bags, the little child eating a lot of popcorn.
I said, hey, what, what is this? You know what, I mean, and then, another situation, we set up a freedom school there, had our freedom school, freedom house, and all these kids, these young kids from the north had set up a library.
I went to Jackson and stayed two days, again, ready to go to college, you know, because I'm going to lead a project after the end of freedom summer and go to college.
So I had to go to Jackson and get some stuff done and see, you know, what money my parents had and stuff like that, and, and to figure out some things.
But anyhow, I'm on my way back to Ruleville, Mississippi, driving along the highway, and this big, canary yellow and black, Buick, passed me on the highway with all of these, with full of little black kids, you know, they were hanging all out, well, I don't think they were hanging out with the women, but this is the way I described it.
This is the way you imagined it.
Hanging all out of the London, you know, let's say this thing's for the six people, it looked like there were ten in there, okay?
And that was this little white person, I wasn't sure it was a little white person, see, Linda Davis had gone home for a day or two to be with her daddy and family, and when she came back, she brought this car.
She drove back from New York, and this car, and while I was away.
So you got all these yellow cars, you know, right?
Man, look at here, I'm really right in the middle of all of this conspicuous happenings, you know what I mean?
And what?
I was curious, this car passed me, and I'm driving in the speed limit.
Speed limit then, I believe, may have been around 55, no more than 60, anyway.
But they had passed me, I was probably driving less than the speed limit, because I wasn't in the hurry, you know, and I didn't want to get stopped by the highway patrol or none of that.
But, so I saw this car and these little kids, and then it looked like I saw a little white woman down in there, and so I'm curious.
So I speed up to see what this is, and this is Linda Davis, one of the Freedom School teachers, and she'd have been the cleaver with all these little kids, and they don't bend to, they don't bend to the driving there, and they, you know, they,
I got back, and I was in shock, you know, and then,
Well, when we got back, and we had a meme, and we were also going to deal with one of the young white girls, we had told them they don't never leave at night especially, but really to stay with in and don't,
and one of the little girls had been to a nightclub out in the Bolivar County, Mississippi with some of the, some, some people who lived there in Cleveland and Ruleville, Mississippi, and you know, not even know how our people were.
But anyway, so we were going to talk about that, so we met, and I, I'm telling you, I was so amazed about it, and when we talked about it and everything,
we just kind of confirmed the fact that we still wanted to be as protective, and we didn't want to place people's lives in jeopardy and stuff like that, and now I'm seeing,
and all of what I thought was happening, it was going to happen, that these children and these old people were developing respect for these kids, I mean, for the, for the blacks who were living in their house, I mean, for the whites who were living in their house, and it was reciprocal.
You know, in other words, they weren't, they were there, and they were calling these people, Mr. and Mrs. and, and calling them around to meetings and started showing up at meetings with them in the car and, and walking through the community, and hey, why would I say something about this other than, be careful.
Always be watchful, you know, it's dangerous, still, but these people, the, just the office that happened, man, they established relationships with these folks, even though I don't think there was any houses that they lived in that had run in water in the house, and, and bathing facilities, there's some pictures of some of these kids with a makeshift shower, where they had put a bucket of water, and, you know,
and, and, and pulling it over the, to, to bathe.
They looked at you, all of a sudden, I felt different about white people. You see them saying, really my objective for going, if you remember, was because of the large black populations, and the possibility of registering these blacks to vote, to send them, send blacks to the legislations,
to the legislature, to the black blacks to local offices, which means that we were going to vote out white people in these offices.
And that's all I thought about. That was my motivation earlier. And I didn't see how we were ever going to connect with these white people in such a way that we could sit across the table from one another as equals.
I just couldn't see it happening. And then these people came, and they are, they are, the people that I suppose the work with, that I'm part of, working with them, living with them, and enjoying them.
And then people brought resources into this, to these homes. You know, they wrote back home, about the situations that they lived in, and those people they sent clothing, for children, shoes, and things, you know.
So, and then they brought books, and it was nothing. I tell you one of the strangest happenings was for me to walk up to a freedom school in the morning, where the kids are a school, and there be classroom full of people, 56 to 77.
And then, the kids are, God, empowerment, you know. So, man, and it always just made me feel so full and empty, empty because I never expected these kinds of things to happen.
And all I saw was, registered voting, voting no matter what, and voting the people in office, I had a replacement them with blacks.
That was, I thought that would be a solution to the problem, but there's another something to them.
I thought that we was going to be able to come to the Delta, register all of these blacks, and go back home within six months. I figured that I would be back in Jackson in school within the next six months.
Not just me, all of us, going to do it across the Delta. Yeah, yeah, I thought, see, I didn't understand the situation. I didn't understand this fear, and I didn't understand the economics. You see, I didn't know.
I was just getting the vote, and so the vote has always been my objective, and it still is. So, I thought we would, after we registered them all, go back home, and I would know these legislators. I would have put them these blacks.
Yeah, I would know these people, and I was always interested in the law, and I said, well, I'll go back to Jackson, get a education, and go into law, become a lawyer.
These people, and Fannie Lou Hamer, and all of these kinds of people that I met, you know, was Fannie Lou Hamer that made me feel closer to a God somewhere.
You know, because I don't know what I thought when, you know, in other words, that religious thing was something, and it was not for me.
You know, I couldn't see the connection of religion, even though Dr. King and all of these ministers, and people were around us all the time, and they were teaching us.
But I was not tuned in to that side of it. Nonviolence was a technique with me.
And they said, if we don't be, if we get violent, then the state, the national government could just wipe us all out and end our movement.
So at least accept nonviolence as a method of bringing about change, and that's how I saw it.
And I didn't see the role of the church accept a meeting place to get things done related to the vote and to the movement.
And when Fannie Lou Hamer often talked, we'd be, one other thing was later during Freedom Summer, you know, we set up our, just before Freedom Summer, we set up our own mark election.
See, we couldn't get registered to vote by the state rules and regulations that they had set up. So what we did was, since we had now got a lot of people coming to the courthouse, to register to vote, and they're not really getting registered, they are, they in turn the way because they couldn't read, couldn't write, and they had to interpret a section of the Mississippi Constitution.
And so we just kept bringing people, and now we decided that, hey, we got a challenge, this reading and writing, because after all, Mississippi, the state have denied Black people and what's still denying the right to education.
People only, in the Delta, only went to school four months out of a year, they had to plan and harvest crops. And so they had a short school session, and then most of the schools were ill-equipped with the kinds of resources that the children needed to make them totally aware of what's happening in their surroundings and around.
Their basic mobility was from the plantation to Chicago, various places in North, once they got out of school. And so they really didn't have any educational, broad-type education to make them more equipped for the jobs and opportunities that they could get up North.
So a lot of training needed to be done. And it was in Ruleville, Mississippi that Charlie Cahop developed this freedom school idea. Once he went to the public school in Ruleville, Mississippi and elsewhere and saw the kinds of things that they were being denied, then he wrote about the need for some supplemental education to the little that they were getting.
I think that would have never happened. I think we were at the point where we were bringing all these people to the register to vote at La Flora County and then Sunflower County. And in La Flora County, SNCC finally got a stable office there.
And then Jimmy Travis, one of our SNCC organizers, was shot and wound it near Greenwood on his way with Bob and Randolph Blackwell in the car. And when Jim and was shot, they couldn't get him into the hospital in the Flora County.
But anyway, when the shots were fired, they hit Jim and they back at his neck, Bob and Blackwell were not wound at all. Then SNCC called a convening, say, a SNCC people in Greenwood and brought SNCC workers from all over the South to Greenwood as a show of force.
Because then white citizens council in Greenwood had vowed that we were not going to have a project in Greenwood. And we pick up here now where Guiard and them had been run out. But we had managed to stay in Greenwood because Sam Block later started to put together the Black leadership there.
Working with churches, the Elks Hall opened its doors to SNCC meetings. And one of the churches there opened their doors to SNCC and then other doors were opened. And Sam then met with Cleveland Jordan, the father of David Jordan, David Jordan, the day. And June Johnson came out of that group in Greenwood.
And he was the main wood you would invest in Simpson and a bunch of other people, their young people got involved in the movement. And we then started to move people to the courthouse in numbers. And they were being rejected.
And Bob and Farman then worked with the Justice Department and they sent John Doar, a Justice Department attorney, investigator down. And Doerl was sympathetic to the movement. I mean he came and talked with us, worked with us, and helped us to get the state of Mississippi showed back some by allowing the applicants who made the money.
The Blacks who made the application for voter registration at the courthouse, they had to maintain those applications. And what we did was people who could not read and write, we had a person station there to let them make their ex and then let's person sign their name for them.
Emma Bale did that in Maryland and some of those young ladies that were Witsnick in Greenwood. But now the Leflore County Board of Supervisors in an effort to stop our voter registration drive, whether registration drive, discontinued the federal food surplus to Black families.
Well talk to families in Blacks were people who needed the most. And they had used these these families dependent upon that food between harvesting season.
They could they missed whatever these food stuff was were very important to these sharecroppers who had a planting season and then a harvesting season and in between there, there were nothing for them to do.
That's why many of them would go to Florida and pick fruit and to other areas to work and then come back home and went in the fall of the year.
And the children only go in the school four months out of a year were getting a very poor education and and their parents most of them had limited education.
So there was these families who wanted their children to get an education and they were wanted educations themselves. And so there was a big move here now.
So what we felt that the momentum we had going with that momentum we needed to try to somehow you know savage something out of that because now the mechanization was taking place on the plantations, the plantators and only didn't need these large families now.
So they are trying to find all the ways possible to get them off the plantation. The tractors are here, the combines and the cotton pickers are coming. So now they just count of through these people away.
And so what we did was set up our own voter registration forms, set up our own registration locations and needs various communities where we were working across the state.
And then we contacted Dick Gregory, Harry Belafonte, Sidney Poitier and these people came down and brought monies to help these people live to find places to live.
So we had a lot of people who were living in the field and food and clothing, we set up a clothing distribution center here. Well in Indianola, not Indianola, in Greenwood and in Ruleville, Mississippi where we had the largest number of people having been evicted from the plantations as a result of the efforts to register vote.
And we set up these mark elections and ran Dr. Aaron Henry, Clark's Dale, Black pharmacist up from Clark's Dale as governor and Rev. Ed King, a white Tougaloo chaplain as Lieutenant Governor and Fannie Lou Hamer Hamer for a Congress person in MS-2, this Delta.
And Victoria Gray Adams in South and Annie Devine in Kent, we got these people to run on our Freedom ballot, in our mark election.
Yes. At this time when you are running this election, almost everybody in Congress is a man.
Yeah. You know how it came to be that SNCC and COFO and the Freedom Party picked three women to run for Congress?
Well the women were the only ones brave enough to do it in those particular communities and they were the active folk. But now Dr. Aaron Henry up in Clark's Dale was a pharmacist and had his freedom as for white, he did not depend on the white people for his living.
So he was independent enough to run as governor and then he was president of state branches of the NAACP. So he had been surviving up there through all of the efforts to killing him and he was jailed and all of that and harassed.
But he was in a position economically to stand on his own. But these in these other communities, you know, they just wasn't in a man who were willing to step out there. But these ladies, these women, Fannie Lou Hamer Hamer and you know her story, she had no fear.
Check this interesting thing about now in order to we're a challenge is being planned to challenge the seats in Congress in Congress from the state and to challenge, you know, these various laws and regulations that reading, writing, interpreting the Constitution and that.
So we're setting up challenges here. We start to take people to the courthouse, whether or not they can read or write or not. And then we started and we didn't listen to that cry about whether you could read. We stopped trying to teach people to interpret the Constitution and all that.
So go in there and write your name, do what, put everything down, you can answer any questions, they give you a section, just write that section over. You copy it down just the way they gave it to you. That's the interpretation of that. That lawyers and Supreme Court justices are arguing over what this stuff mean. And they're asking you a person who have been limitedly educated, you know, it's designed to keep us from resting above.
Now, we decided, we got these ladies to run, but now we were planning to bring a challenge in Congress. And the only way to do that was at least one of these people to bring the challenge needed to be legally candidate, had to be a candidate who was now challenging the system, not just a mock-a-legs on the actual ballot.
And that chose Fannie Lou Hamer. And so now, one day, I will see you the call one morning, early, from the COFO office in Jackson, said, go get Fannie Lou Hamer and take her to Jackson, Mississippi to get her legally qualified to run for Congress.
Okay. Well, I can do that, but now I'm thinking. See, I'm into this mentality that white people are in Congress, men, and it's going to require education. See, my brain is back in this frame of mind about the lack of education.
So Mrs. Hamer is a sixth grade scholar. And I'm being told to go and get her and take her and get her legally qualified to run for Congress. Now, I don't know, but I don't suspect there's not a single person in Congress without at least college degree.
I don't know, maybe it may have been back then. I don't know, but I don't know any because I don't know none. I'm familiar with Adam Clayton Powell Jr. And I'm familiar with William L. Dawson and them people because of Chicago and New York. And the fact that these are places that we looked to for our leadership. Okay. It's all the reason I'm familiar with them.
But so they, I get up, drive to remove them all the way over there, thinking that the rest of my day will be spent doing whatever I usually do. I go to family, New Hamers house, walking because I would go to her house almost every day when I was in the area to find out what she needed me to do.
What she wanted me to do or whatever plans I've gotten from cofo, off his and bob, and them to get done. And so because she was doing something every day.
I got to miss his Hamers house, went in as always, her husband, get me a cup of coffee, drink a gin or something. And he loved, he drank, he drank 100 proof grand day.
So it's around 10 o'clock in the day when I get there. Sometimes I get there in the afternoon and we'd have our head. But anyway, I said, I need to see Miss Hamer this morning, bathe and pap said, okay, I'll get him.
He goes in there, get Miss Hamer, she come out, I'm on the couch sitting out there and as a Miss Hamer. I was called from the cofo office in Jackson. And they told me to come pick you up, transport you to Jackson, Mississippi to the Secretary of State's office and get you qualified.
To run for Congress. I expected her to say, Mac, I ain't gonna do that. You know, I just don't I ain't qualified. She said, Mac, keep your seat. And I'll be right with you.
I get to feel that Miss Hamer was always ready. I told people I said, look, this woman was always ready. I never I've gone to her house.
25 times. And never did she say, I'm not going to date. Never. But anyway, now she's gone, she didn't got up and going back there to get ready.
I'm sitting up out there trying to figure out why she's going to do this. You know what I'm trying to figure out why is she going to do this. I expected her to tell me, Mac, I don't I ain't qualified.
Yeah. And I would have got her left or whatever else we were going to do that day. And she came back. We got in the car, drove to Jackson, went up to the Secretary of State's office, went up to the desk of the Secretary of State and told the lady, we wanted that Miss Hamer want to run for Congress.
White woman, Buck Tye, looked at us, went back there to the door and there were a bunch of other white women back there, desk, you know, I guess the Secretary isn't very as other people. And said, hey, y'all, there's two niggas out here, said they want to run for Congress.
Look here, in a few minutes, that door was full and they all looking out there, that's like we want, you know, we want a free show or something, you know, you know, they were looking out there at us and
you should charge them.
Yeah, we could have, but look here. And that's why they did that for a few minutes and she saw we were serious.
She brought us a stack of papers over there and said, the candidate, they've got to fill out these papers.
We take the papers, go back out into the car door of the Capitol, fill out these papers, the best of our ability.
Evidently, we did good, after we brought them back to us, she accepted them and she said, wait a minute, you're not ready to get it.
Now, this is the last day to qualify to run for Congress, last day.
She, we brought them back to us, she checked them over and she said, and we were fixing to go and she said, wait a minute now, you can't leave yet.
Said the candidate have to pay, if you're going to run as a Democrat.
I'd been told, we're going to run as a Democrat, go for it.
Said, you need to bring me a check for $500 to be paid to the Democratic Party Executive Committee.
And it should be made out to a guy by the name of Bidwell Adams, who is the Secretary of the Democratic Party.
And that check need to be here with these papers.
Okay? So we go back out into the car door.
And then we come back for the people that don't know this time period, $500. How much money is $500?
Now it's not a lot of money, but then that was some of the sharecroppers wasn't making $500 a year.
So she needs a year's earnings in some more?
Because some people wouldn't get in about $1000.
They'd clear in maybe $1000 after the harvest season.
And people working in the various restaurants and places like that were making about 50 cents an hour.
So this is a series of money.
But now we knew that the co-fold people that told us to come here, that they must have known.
Because some of the people in the Justin Mars was the person who called me and told me.
So I go back out there and we get to a telephone booth and call the co-folders and tell them we need a check for $500.
Mars said, don't leave. It'll be there.
Okay?
Shortly from the co-fold office on Lynch Street and some getting the check made out and everything,
brought us up to around 12 or 30 or 1 o'clock.
Well it wasn't car at one because these ladies wasn't going to lunch yet.
So it wasn't quite. They got there, it brought the $500.
It took the $500 and carried it to her and we started to leave.
And she says, hold it. You're not finished yet.
And said, now at the time, the candidate qualifies,
he or she must name their campaign manager.
And the campaign manager signs the form here.
Okay? So we go back out there in the car at all.
We call the COFO office and says, look, we need a person here to become Mrs. Hamer's campaign manager.
They said, don't leave somebody or be there.
So we go back out into the car at all. These ladies go to lunch and everything.
Then around three o'clock in the afternoon, nobody has come yet.
Four o'clock. The white lady says, look, we're closing at five.
This is the last day to qualify.
And unless the campaign manager is here and signing in,
then you can't get qualified to run for Congress.
So we call the COFO office again, nobody answers the phone.
So we said, okay, probably Jess and Maris is on his way or they're getting some back.
Four thirty. The lady come back out and says, you got thirty minutes.
And we leave five minutes of five getting ready to get out of here.
So, friend of Lu and I, go back out into the car.
And we're sitting there with our hands and our hands and our hands trying to figure out what to do.
And then Mrs. Hamers gets up, take a couple steps around.
I thought she was thinking, well, I won't get the chance to run.
She says, man, that's a yes, man.
Go in there and put your name on them papers and let's go home.
I mean, she didn't say, would you or you ought to, she says,
man, get up and go in there and put your name on them papers and let's go home.
Look here, look here. I don't know.
Maybe I said to myself, shit, why me?
But I said to her, I said, Mrs. Hamers.
I said, I'm not qualified to be known campaign manager.
She looked at me and she said, man, you know enough about being a campaign manager as I know about running for cons.
Put your name on the papers.
So, I go in there and put my name on them papers.
I never thought about not doing it.
I just couldn't see why I ought to do it.
In other words, I didn't decide this because if it had been left to me, we wouldn't be here in the first place.
You see what I'm saying?
So, we went in there and put our name on the papers and the lady said, now everything is complete.
She seems like she's actually more helpful than you might expect.
Well, she could have told us all of this upfront.
She could have said, look, fill out these papers.
You got to have a $500 check and the campaign manager got to be named before this process is complete.
She could have told us that all upfront.
But she'd drag it on each step by step.
So, anyway, so I became her campaign manager by default.
I mean, nobody else showed up.
You were the right person anyway.
No, I didn't.
I didn't know that because I really didn't bargain for it.
But now, as we were leaving, I thought about this really deeply, truly within me,
I've always wanted to move step up to a challenge.
To get our challenge at the courthouse back when I first got there,
then all along the way, I'm being challenged to step up and do what I really kind of deepened me wanted to do
was to be like Medgar Evers, like, you know, Amzie Moore, and these people that I met, my heroes.
But then, if they had just given me just a little inch out of a bad towel.
It seems like we were SNCC.
A lot of people did things they never thought they would do.
If anybody had told me back in Jackson in 1961 that I would have done some of the stuff that I've done,
man, I didn't look.
Because I've done some things.
The challenges didn't stop.
You know, I'm way off into this.
And then I'm going to get on up there to freedom, so we can get out through what we can do.
But I remember in Greenville, Mississippi, Charlie and I were there.
And we had a little youth group.
We had set up.
We were working on a youth group.
And the bus station in Greenville was segregated.
This is 1963.
The bus station, everything in Greenville was segregated.
Greenville was the so-called liberal community in the delk.
But segregation exists.
And the bus station trains everything that was segregated.
But the black folks had a little bit more freedom there because of the connection that blacks had.
For instance, James Carter, a black businessman on Nelson Street on the press and shot.
And he was the head of a voter registration drive there.
Edwards, a black funeral home director.
And you had a doctor page, Dr. Matthews.
You know, these guys were involved.
And then you had the Delta Democrat-Times, the newspaper there, that didn't tolerate the clan and the clan activities.
And they shot any involvement like that.
And they had Greenville had two black detectives.
They said there was not another black law enforcement officer in the whole state except Indianola.
Indianola had a black policeman. They put him in office in 1955.
Well, to keep down racial disturbance.
To keep down racial violence.
And to, if there was a lawsuit or anything came up, there's this black who's in charge of the black area.
Because here in Indianola, a guy by the name of Nathaniel Jack, Colin Slim, was appointed.
He was the first uniform black policeman in the state.
But he could not arrest white people.
He could not do anything on the white side of town.
And he better not mess around too much with the black lackeys over on his side of town.
So he was there to keep the peace, to keep down racial disturbances and mercy is possible.
We had some encounters with him down the road.
Now, in Greenville, they had two black detectives.
And these were nice guys with us.
We never had trouble out of them.
But when we challenged segregation there, they arrested our kids.
And they were holding a trial in the city courtroom.
And Charlie and I were there with the kids.
They had, there were blacks standing outside, you know, hundred people standing outside, blacks who couldn't get into the courtroom.
And I had been in the courtroom before because I had gotten a traffic citation back earlier.
And I knew good and well all of them seats couldn't be taken.
Was that many white people there, you know?
So I walked up and went into the courtroom and the side where the blacks were were full.
And there was a whole section over here with no white people in it.
You know what I did, I took a seat over there.
And a black policeman rushed over to where I was and told me that there was somebody outside who wanted to see me.
And when I walked out that door he fastened, that he locked the door, locked me out.
I went around to the other door and they wouldn't let me back in.
So I went out on the outside and I went to tell them these people that said, look, there's plenty room in the courthouse.
They have got you standing out here because they don't want to break their segregation policy.
They don't want to use that side.
We need to demand the right to get them seats.
Police when came out there and told me I was trying to inside a ride and arrested me.
But being jailed, Charlie learned I was in jail and he picked up where I left off.
He put him in jail.
So Charlie and I are in jail now.
And so we, our cases went to court.
Charlie was now in Atlanta somewhere and when the case went to court.
And so I went to court because I was still in the delta and they were able to subpoena, give me my subpoena.
And I had, I think I had two blacks on my jury.
All I needed was one that disagreed.
And that guy put me in jail.
So I had to go back to jail.
Now the meantime, R. Jess Brown, one of the three black lawyers in the state, came to represent me and appealed my case to the next high school.
So between 1963 and 1965, I believe, or 1666, somewhere in there.
My case came before the US Supreme Court.
It was before Richard Nixon got into office.
And you see, so whatever that was in that period.
And by the time the ruling came down, Richard Nixon's in office, the court is turning.
And they remanded my case back to the local court so that, and hope that they would resolve the question.
They didn't want to deal with it.
And this is before the US Supreme Court.
And what happened was they ordered me back to jail, the City of Greenville, the guy who's the prosecutor, I was told by R. Jess Brown.
Said he just wanted my black ass in jail, or arid and so and so.
He wanted me in jail because it was discussed.
Why don't we just let the nigga go?
I want him.
Lawyer was named Robert Shaw.
Robert Shaw.
So the case, I went to jail and I got out on a habeas corpus motion.
And then the case went back up to the Supreme Court.
The case went to the Supreme Court three times.
By the time it got up there, Richard Nixon was in and the court had changed.
And they were remanded back to the Greenville.
They didn't, and the city of Greenville ordered me and child, and the cop to go to jail.
The cop never came.
Now I was in New York when this last ruling came down.
And if I had stayed in New York, I probably wouldn't have never went to jail.
So what I did was I set up the Stokely Carmichael came to visit me while I was in jail.
And he told the people in Greenville, the law enforcement officials said, look.
So we're trying to put enough bomb for our people and spending our money and putting up bomb.
Said the next time y'all put one of our people in jail, we ain't going to pay you nothing.
We're going to break him out.
Now we're going to break him out.
So here I come to jail.
You know what I mean?
They asked me, and I threw my lawyer told him that I will present myself at the Greenville City
jail at noon, from this particular day.
So what happened was Frank Smith was in town, and Frank came by, the SNCC office there,
and I stayed there all night, so they wouldn't know where I was, because I'm planning to surprise them.
So Frank gave me a ride over to, and we popped right in front of the city jail,
where I'm supposed to present myself.
And at 12 o'clock, I got out of the van and walked over to the jail,
and police were down on that end, and all around on the other end, you know, expecting to get me.
I walked right in there, presented myself at the desk and said, I'm Charles McLaurin,
and I'm supposed to be locked up today.
And the police went from all up on the other end, all out there came in.
Look at it, look at it, the last thing they expected was me to walk in there.
They were going to arrest me, well, if they see me, they were going to put the handcuffs on me.
And they were fixing to put the handcuffs on me right there in jail, standing in the...
I'm presented myself.
And there was a, and the police chief, at that time, was a guy named Burnley,
a fairly nice guy, you know, by Mississippi standards, white, Mississippi standards, for white men,
he was a fairly nice guy, and he was the chief.
And he came over and told him to put the handcuffs on me, and we went on round end, talked a little while,
and they locked me up, and I stayed in jail several days.
And, you know, we didn't try no more appeals.
I don't know if I would have said this before the camera, but it came to me no harm.
And he's dead, is that the chief of policemen, Burnley, and I talked it over,
and we agreed that I would stay in jail a couple nights in the day.
And he would release me to go to college, to go to school, because I had told him about how to plan to go.
And so one day, late one evening, jailed those open and I walked out,
and I was standing, that I would not come back to Greenville and cause trouble for at least a year.
And that's how I got out of that.
Yeah, Richard Nixon is not.
Earl Warren is gone.
And Richard Nixon had appointed somebody, you know, I don't know what's happening, but anyway,
they gave the city of Greenville away out.
They just, you know, let me go.
You know, after all, I mean, I hadn't done nothing.
They said I made statements calculated to provoke a breach of the peace.
Mr. Nash, what's the quote, Charles?
Yeah, making statements calculated to breach the peace.
I remember when it was around 1966, because now, 1966 or 1967,
because now I'm employed as a social services director for one of the Head Start programs that we had set up,
Amzie Moore, for Amzie Moore Moore and the rest of us had set up.
And I remember that when I left, you know, I didn't even tell the people
that I, well, it worked.
Well, so I was in jail that night on the day.
And then I came home and come back to work.
Yeah.
And stayed there until 1972.
How many days were you supposed to be if you had served the whole time?
I had a hundred, I had a hundred and eighty days.
And I believe around five or six hundred dollars fine.
So I had to pay the fine and serve the days.
Or they could, whatever they could.
Did you pay the fine?
No.
They just...
You remember that, you remember that it kept going up to the court.
And then finally, I was in jail.
So I'm going to serve my time instead of the fine.
But then the chief holding the jail door.
And do you know later he became the...
Barrona became the mayor of the City of Greenville.
And about two years later, I was working for National Council of Negro Women.
And he was on the committee or something for National Council of Negro Women in Greenville.
And we ran into one another and talked and joked.
You know, he was a nice fellow.
But Barrona was an exceptional white person.
Because I didn't really know any until the freedom...
After we got freedom summer, I didn't really know any white people.
Had no respect for them and I know they had none for me.
I just, you know, this white freedom summer brought me around,
and these other people from the north.
But after we met...
After Fannie Lou Hamer got to run for Congress, we campaigned across MS-2.
Because we wanted to change MS-2.
See, MS-2 had always been running...
Cut, so did it run along in the river, which meant that it picked up all of the black counties,
which gave it a black majority district.
And that district was the district that John R. Lynch,
the black who held it was the congressman of Proud to Reconstruction, you know, doing Reconstruction.
And he had a...
But then the Mississippi legislature had come and cut the district's diagonally
and split the black vote and attached these heavily white communities to the east as a part of the Delta.
And therefore diluted our votes to a point that we couldn't elect the congressman.
But then we filed lawsuits and some congressional hearings were held.
And I presented a plan for redistricting MS-2.
And G.R. always, and I always...
He always said that he was in the federal court up there and they brought up the Maglar and played.
And when he discovered it was my player from then on, we always joke about the fact he said,
anybody going to tell me nothing about Joe McDonald.
Joe McDonald presented a player for congressional redistricting and it was considered.
And so...
But anyhow, Fannie Lou and I ran and ran.
Then the lawsuits were filed by now Henry J. Kirksey, who a mapmaker from Jackson,
and who became, I believe, the first senator to serve in the Senate since reconstruction black to serve.
And he resigned in Mississippi.
In the state Senate.
Yeah, in the state Senate.
And he resigned, you remember?
He didn't stay there because he said he wasn't doing no good there.
I mean, you know, one in 52.
It's 52 members I think of the Senate.
And one in 52, what did Niga do?
So, you know, a lot of people think the movements over when the voting rights act passes or when Dr. King killed.
But you and Miss Hamer, not just you and Miss Hamer, but I know that you and Miss Hamer worked on a number of really important projects.
You know, one of the things, you know, after the challenge in Atlantic City, New Jersey in 1964,
a lot of movement people just kind of dispersed.
And, you know, SNCC died as an organization and field organization with field people out there.
But now, but François and I, you know, because I can understand that, you know, the dissolution and the, you know, the feeling of the laws.
And, but François and I didn't feel that way because we had invested, you know, so much in the movement earlier.
And we were Mississippians.
See, a lot of these other people who were going back home, who got angry and everything went home or went to doing something else, we were coming home.
And the same problems that exist when we went to Atlantic City, New Jersey was still here.
The so-called compromise that they offered us at an Atlantic City, New Jersey was nothing.
And, uh, Fannie Lou and the rest of us delegates from the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party had rejected it.
And that the regular Democratic Party delegation from Mississippi had come home, had refused to pledge a law,
to the pledge law, to the Democratic Party, or to the support the candidate of the Democratic Party.
And, you know, Lyndon B. Johnson, with the one who wanted to be president, and he had, and he would have come up with this compromise,
and one seat at large, representing no value. They didn't even tell us that we were going to have one seat in the Mississippi delegation.
They were one, two seats at large, no, with no representation, no way.
And so, François and I said, hey, that ain't nothing.
And, um, people say, François and I did that.
The whole delegation voted with her. There was no dissension in the Mississippi delegation, even though there were some who would have taken this.
Now, they were even, Lyndon B. Johnson's group were going to even name the two people who were going to get the seats.
See, they weren't going to say, uh, we're going to have a vote, let them vote among themselves, and select the person, the two people.
They named them, you know, so, um, do you think they would have made a difference if the delegation could have chose a zone to represent those people who have been different about that?
I don't know, but I do know this. If the choice had been thrown to us, it would have at least been discussed, you know, about us.
But this way, there was no discussion. You know, the discussion took place between Hubert H. Humphrey, Walter Mondale, Joseph Rauh Jr, Walter Reuther, Dr. Aaron Henry, Rev. Ed King, and some of these people.
But now, the decision had already been made when they brought it to them. That Lyndon B. Johnson just wanted to get rid of this, because he feared he would lose what he thought he had.
He thought he had a Southern base. He had some Dixiecrats down here in the South, across the South, who really were not Democrats, but they were holding on to this democratic patronage, that they had all gained over the years as a result of the nine, the population, the Black populations in these states to participate in the primary.
And the general election, you know, and then in the Caucasus. And so if we had been able to vote, that solid South wouldn't have exist.
And what we went there to show them was what that James O. Eastland and some of the other senators were saying was that the Black folks don't want to vote.
Our Mark election said we did. We got 80,000 votes to, you know, running our candidates. Then we bring to Atlantic City, New Jersey a delegation parallel to that met party rules and evidence of our denial of being deprived of the right to vote.
And then they decide that if Johnson go with us, he lose the South. I mean, even though he lost the South anyway. I mean, after all, Barry Goldwater was the winner of the South. And what happened?
Immediately following the Democratic Party rejection. I mean, the Democratic Party rejection of us, our delegation, the South turns Republican.
All of these white people in the party who wanted nothing to do with Black folks in office voting ran to the Republican Party.
And so now you have a solid Republican South. Those same states are now in the Republican column. And the voting rights act that came out of our struggle and the marches and Selma, Alabama, the Challenger Atlantic City, New Jersey was kind of thrown to the Blacks.
Okay, this is y'all's party. You know, and so it's made up today of those loyal Democrats who still in the Democratic Party, but most of the white population Republicans and the only ones that in the South, especially in Mississippi, who voting Republican,
but they are sitting in Democratic seats. They don't tell nobody because if they did nine out of ten times, and especially where we are in majority population, they wouldn't hold those office. Now, Henry Kurskick drew legislative maps and he drew congressional maps. And he drew municipal and county maps and reapportion and redistricting.
Especially in the Delta have led to, you know, blacks in office. And in 1962, there was not one black elected official in this whole state other than in the small town of Mound Bayou, Mississippi. And one of the other, some of them little communities up there.
All black from the get founded by slaves, you know, I team on Gumber. I'm going to get through it a minute. My wife, I know she always tell me to stop talking sometime. But anyway, you know, these.
Oh, okay. Well, let me tell you this and then we're going to get on your question. I remember that.
Amzie Moore Moore told me. And I didn't at that time, I didn't know it that Isaiah T. Montgomery was the last black legislator in the state legislature.
At the time in the 1890s when the legislature took away our right to vote and that he voted with the whites. I didn't know that it for.
And when I found when I and then I went back and read about, you know, all of this. And it really, it really just kind of hurt me, hurt me to know that that he did that. And then I tried to read his logic. And then I compared his logic with the thinking of Book of T Washington, you know, and I just, but I came later to respect.
These people as individuals. And, but I just it was it's been so hard for me to kind of realize that a person like Fannie Lou Hamer, you know, sharecropper stood up against the system.
And here these guys were Isaiah T. Montgomery was a landowner, you know, they were the slaves offered the plantation of the president of the Confederacy. Yeah, offered a Jefferson Davis's Brierfield Plantation.
You know, and they had come up here for freedom, bought and set up this town and everything. And he ought to have been waving the American flag when they was waving the Confederate flag. But hey, things happen.
Okay. He told me that when Fannie Lou Hamer was ill, he met with her in the hospital. He went to visit. Can you tell us about that? Or she asked you?
Yeah. When I when I learned that Fannie Lou Hamer was in the hospital and that she was in Mound Bayou, Mississippi, I immediately went to see her. And we talked about the movement.
And she was kind of he was, she was delirious. And she was just kind of talking out of her head. And the first day I went to see her. And so I only stayed a short time. And we talked about kind of when we we ran for Congress.
We talked about the lawsuit that she filed in the town of Sunflower, Hamer versus Campbell in 1967. And how that Robert Clark getting elected. So that particular time.
I left there and three days later I went back to visit her. And at this time she just wanted to talk about.
First she went to talking about and that's the way that she may be fixing the die. And she said, she said, Mac, I'm going to be here. I'm not going to be here to see this thing through.
And I said, oh, I'm there. Say, well, come on now. You're going to be here a lot longer than I will. And I you know, talk like that. And she said, Mac, I want you to promise me.
And I kind of said to myself, every time I promise, family, we got off into something that I really didn't want to be off into. You know, and I said, come on, I'm saying, she's a Mac. I live on a plantation all my life.
And I do not want to be buried back on a plantation. And I said, Miss Amy, why are you talking about this? I mean, you're not, I mean, you're going to be here. You're going to be here. She said, Mac, promise me.
And I said, well, and I thought about it. I said, well, she's going to be here longer than I am. Why not make this promise? I ain't going to have to live up to it. I said, okay, Miss Amy, I promise you will not be buried on a plantation.
And they had given up medication. She said, I'm going to rest now. And I left.
Few nights later, I was called, well, what happened? About three days after that, one of Mrs. Hamer's relatives and Paa Paymer came to my office. I was working for a community action agency in Indianola.
I was director of purchasing and personnel. And she, this lady came in and Pap, and he said, Mac, he's a Mrs. Hamer pass last night.
Man, you're talking about, I don't think I was, I'm showing off scared now. I was almost as scared as I was when I was walking up to that courthouse because it came back to me. Now, whatever, what am I into here?
I promised her that she would not be buried on a plantation. And really, this is just a few days after that. I hadn't had time to even think about that no more. And really, I didn't plan to because I think she would outlive me.
And he said, the body is in Greenwood, at Maxwelline Film Home. So I said, OK. And I'll meet you back in Ruleville.
I get myself, Jim is strong, freeing here in Indianola, and Eunice Jenkins, our freeing. These are people employed in the Head Start program, and all of us who knew and loved work with me as the same.
Eunice Jenkins and I, Jim is strong, drove to Maxwelline Film Home in Greenwood. And right away, I was depressed when I saw the Film Home.
Because again, I've got these, I don't know, you might want to call them false values. I'm looking for nice looking building. And just plays look like a little shanty plantation shack to the film home.
And he'd go in and we'd, and he showed me how he's going to bury Mrs. Hamer. I said, I just couldn't see this. And I just couldn't see it. And when, and I saw him, he was standing there with a beat up hat on.
And would all do respect to Mr. Maxwelline. And he was wearing spats, you know, on the shoes. I mean, this is 1967. And he has on spats. And, and a suit.
I was just not, he was an elderly man. But none of this came to mind because I'm living in this time. And it seemed like he was living in a pass. And so I said, well, we're going to have to get together. And I'll let you, let you know something.
I mean Mr. Hamer and her and whoever there was with him in Ruleville. We'll meet you there at three o'clock today. He said, okay.
In the meantime, we're on our way back to India now. I'm going back to the office to sign out. Let him know where I was. That I, what I was going to be doing.
And we will stop on a highway by Henry Espy, who is a burial, directing Espich, you know, the funeral home in the phone call. And he said, look, he said, I know y'all have been down to Mr. Maxwelline.
He said, I got nothing against Mr. Maxwelline. But I would like to bury Fannie Lou Hamer. He said, come on, let me show you how I would bury him.
So we followed him back to Greenwood and went to his burial to his, to his funeral home. And he showed us how I mean that we walk in. This is a library.
Yes, I mean, hey, this is what he's offering would be suitable in my estimation. Limited knowledge about the area and everything.
Suitable for the president of the United States of America. And so right away, I'm so Jenkins soul and Jimmy. Okay. Now, I said, what would it cost for this to do this?
To do this kind of thing. He said, don't worry about the money. I said, we got to worry about the money, Mr. Espy." He said, don't worry about the money.
He said, but I need, I need you all in order. If you're going to let me bury, I said, you can bury. He said, but I need to sign these paper to get the body from that other funeral home.
So we got the papers out and I signed them, Jenkins signed them and Jim and signed them that he could bury them as the same.
So in the meantime, we go on, he brought us back to where we left my car out on the highway right outside of Greenwood. And before you get to Mississippi Valley State (College.
And we came on back to, if we got back there, then I went back to my office, signed out, went to Ruleville, Mississippi. And we told Mr. Maxline that we were turning the body over to Central Bear, it was at Central Bear.
And so he communicated with Mr. Espy, and Mr. Espy paid him for whatever he had done. And while we was there, the question came up about Mrs. Hamer's burial.
And I said, one of the things we want to make sure is that she's not buried on a plantation. And then there was some discussion with about that because there's some people that disagreed about her being, they wanted to bury her.
Well, the other blacks were being buried out there. And I said, no, we're not going to bury them as the same one on a plantation. So where are we going to bury them?
And I said, well, we got a few days to decide this. And so we left there and the next evening, some guys came to me.
I asked you a question now. So where do the black folks get buried at this time?
All of the plantations, the burial spots on a plantation. They hold on a plantation. There's a church and then there's a burial ground.
Now Galilee has a church. The first time I ever seen a burial ground at the church, remember I grew up in Jackson. And the cemetery were not on churches.
And so they had one out there. But the one they wanted to use was down there on a plantation just across the highway from where Mrs. Hamer lived on that other plantation on Sidney Livingston's plantation.
That's where they wanted to bury her. And because they went on, I think they want to talk about other relatives. Whatever it was, I wasn't listening. I wasn't into that.
We left that at evening with the understanding that century is going to bury her, but we didn't know who her.
Because at this point, we don't know. Now, two young men that I'm not going to name came up to me and they were interested in Freedom Farm.
And they said that they had gotten approval from Mrs. Hamer to reopen Freedom Farm or something like that, or that they could have with me.
And she had told them that they had a meeting that I was the... that Macklon should be in that meeting. And that's why they had come to me.
And so then they held that meeting that next evening and I came. Now, while I'm there, I learned that Mrs. Hamer owns some property there in the city.
Six lives, big location, where she's buried right now. All of that property there was owned by Freedom Farm.
And they wanted me to sign papers, allowing them to take possession of the property through Freedom Farm.
To read, the staff of the Freedom Farm had become Booker T. Washington in limbo since the manager Joe Harris had died.
And it had just kind of just been there in limbo, you know, hovering.
And then when I learned about that, and they wanted me to sign these papers, I said, oh, I want to see this place.
And carried me out there and showed me the place. And now a burden was lifted off me.
You know, all of a sudden, I have a place to bury Fannie Lou Hamer, and it's not on a plantation.
But what I didn't know was that you could not bury a person within the city limits.
Unless there was a proof cemetery or something already existing or something there.
Attorney Cleve McDowell, the second black to go into Ole Miss after Meredith, who had to leave, and who had gotten his law degree down at Southern in Texas.
And Texas suddenly. And he was a member of the NAACP.
And I knew him, I kind of knew of him, because I knew his sister worked for us in the cap agents.
So when he learned about Mrs. Hamer's death, that next morning, he showed up in my office in Indian old.
And I told him what the situation was. And he said, don't worry. We'll bury Mrs. Hamer on that property.
So I let that alone for the right then. Now, what about our funeral? You know?
So, everybody's got me stuck with this. You see what I'm talking about?
So, man again, I'm frightened. And when I got to remove them, Owen Brooks was at Mrs. Hamer's house.
And I told him that Henry Espy had to bury him.
And I think Henry Espy came through that afternoon and him and Owen talked.
And Owen said, well, what about the funeral?
And so, he said, Mac, I've started to make these nights.
I've been calling these people. I've been doing this. And I've been doing that.
I said, you got to, you, you plan it. Or, I said, you got it.
And he gladly accepted it. You know? And he talked with Henry.
And then later, I learned that it's going to cost nearly $10,000. That's their only reason.
The count of funeral that Henry has here, it was over $8,000, and almost $9,000 to $10,000.
The three of us, Unison and Jim and have signed papers to them and given them by the, to the man.
Don't worry about the call. But it's cost nearly $10,000.
And so, now what happened was, after Owen got that, I was relieved.
All right. And then that afternoon, Cleve came and said that he had met with the City Board of Allerman and Enruvel.
And at that time, the City had, Eruvel had a female man, Dr. Virginia Talbert.
And she had passed a resolution doing Mrs. Hamer Day when Mrs. Hamlet was sick,
making Hamer Day, designating Hamer Day. And we had had a big gathering and everything.
And she had spoke, nice lady by a Mississippi standards.
So, Henry Espy and Owen got together on the burial and Cleve created the legal thing and had that set up.
And so, she could be buried then. And Henry Espy had the body.
Now, all I had to do now was try to take this pressure off my heart, need.
And so, when I learned that it was, it was causing, what it was causing the burial,
then I wouldn't told my friends, they said, man, we got, we got no $10,000.
But Owen Brooks had agreed to take care of this.
And at that time, Delta Ministry was, he was the director of Delta Ministry.
And Charles Bannerman was the president and CEO of MACE (Mississippi Action for Community Education) + MACE (Mississippi Action for Community Education) + Delta Foundation, a MACE (Mississippi Action for Community Education) + Delta Foundation.
So, MACE (Mississippi Action for Community Education) + Delta Foundation paid the, paid the bill. And we buried her.
And out there, and wasn't on, nothing out there but her grave site.
And in one of my papers, I wrote after that, that I hope that someday somebody here in this town
would pick this up and run with. And 10 things over the years, there were a lot of, you know,
there were some of the people, some people had me arrested about donating that property to, for them to be buried.
And so, over the years, nothing happened with that grave site for several years.
And then a little later, in ruralville, working for the Head Start program,
raised some money and put a headstone out there.
Head Start people raised that money. And then later, later named Pat Thompson,
a graduate of Delta State at MARA of Mrs. Hamon, Victoria Gray Adams and the mother started to hold some means out there
and had it Bennie G. Thompson and others. And then slowly, the things started to develop.
And this had a jaw and the lady who is over the thing now now got elected to the board of all of them.
And she worked with the city to get a self-help grant to put the provision out there.
And some other people, white and black, help come up with some of the monuments and things out there.
And I made a promise that one day I would have her standing in the Delta.
You know, I saw a picture of her standing in a cotton field looking back she was surveying over the area.
And so I was able to sail that idea to several people and to Pat Thompson.
And up in New Jersey, people up there had been carrying on a program in Mrs. Hamer's honor since she spoke up there back in the credentials committee.
And they decided that they would work with us to raise $100,000 to put a statue out there.
So we started that project and two years after we started it, we erected that statue.
Still no work in progress.
I've seen when I first came to the grave, it was just a little crime scene.
Yeah, see all of that other land around there was a part of Mrs. Hamon.
We donated, in order to get her buried there, we donated all of that land to the city of Ingenola, not in to city of Ruleville, Mississippi, in order to create that special burial site for her.
And so the city of Ruleville, Mississippi owned the rest of that land.
You know, when they've used it as, I guess, to help economic development.
But it was really our intention that that land all become a part of Mrs. Hamer's burial site.
We expect to have a move our museum into a building that we would erect down there.
And that we would have a paved parking area out there, a beautiful area parking.
So we ain't told the city about that yet.
Yeah, my grandmother used to always tell me, she said, to foretell is to forewarn.
As you know, James Meredith, the first black to know and let graduate from Ole Miss.
Graduated.
You know, there was a big flare up up there while he was dead and some people were killed.
But he later graduated from New York, I think, in New York.
And then after he was back for a while, and a few other prizes, he decided to walk from the Tennessee State Line to Jackson, Mississippi to encourage voter registration and black participation, political participation.
And he called it a march against fear.
So on a particular day in June 1966, James Meredith stepped off on his walk alone.
And after he had gone a short distance, he was shot down from ambush by a white person.
While he's in the hospital recuperating Dr. King and Floyd McKissick of CORE, and Stokely Carmichael Michael,
who had just become chairperson of the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee, succeeding John Lewis, met with Meredith and got his approval to continue the march alone.
Highway 51 into Jackson, Mississippi, where there would be a big rabbit.
So the march took off from where Meredith was shot down and was headed to Grenada, Mississippi, Mississippi, that was going to be their first overnight state.
And Fannie Lou Hamer Hamer, who had been talked with Stokely Carmichael and Dr. King and others about the march, had she wasn't able to be there because of other speaking engagements.
And that lawsuit, Hamer v. Campbell, 358 F.2d 215, had been filed and was encoded.
And they had been known that that suit was going to come down.
So what had happened, Guillard and the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party, what was left of it, had moved the official office,
state office to sunflower, the small town of sunflower in the Delta.
And when that march started, that case was Hamer versus Campbell dealing with the right to vote and to be able to participate for blacks to participate in the electoral process.
That lawsuit set back throughout the elections in two communities in the town of sunflower and in the town of Moorhead, Mississippi.
And it set up a voter registration period for blacks to get registered and then to hold new elections.
And so that's what that particular was about.
Now that we had the FDP office in sunflower and the march was to march against fear about voter registration, Fannie Lou Hamer Hamer set up a march from that small town to Indianola, to the courthouse and asked me and Joe Harris to go and ask Dr. King and Stokely Carmichael to bring the march through the city.
To deviate from Highway 61 in order to bring it so that blacks in the Delta could get the feel of this big march and hopefully encourage them to register and to vote.
So we won the approval of Dr. King and that group that they would bring the march along Highway 7 to Greenwood and stayed at night in Greenwood.
So then a forward group, a group made up of myself, Stokely Carmichael, James Jones and another guy, I'm not sure whether that was Willie Ricks or not.
But anyway, we were to go and secure a place where we decided Greenwood was it because our history in the Delta was in Greenwood.
And we had had a lot of things happen there, Travis was shot there, the National SNCC office was located there.
And so we said we're going to stay in Greenwood.
So the marches took off, we took off. We got to Greenwood and Stokely Carmichael went to talk to the black leadership there about putting up on a school ground, stone street elementary school or in the black community.
And we were going to leave and Jones and I went to Mississippi Valley State (College to meet with Mississippi Valley State (College, the president to see about an alternative spot.
We were so sure we were going to get Greenwood, but we wanted an alternative spot in the case we did not.
So we would rather put up on that campus anyway because of the kids there.
So we went to Mississippi Valley State (College, got permission to meet with Mississippi Valley State (College.
Mississippi Valley State (College told us we could meet with him around three or four o'clock that day in his house.
So Cleve, James Jones and I went to Mississippi Valley State (College's house and he read us a prepared statement that nine us used to the campus.
And he's flanked by about eight or ten white state troopers.
And right after that they run us off the campus.
And we went back to Greenwood and we learned that Stokely Carmichael is in jail, that he had been arrested for trying to erect a tent on the stone street elementary campus.
Now Stokely Carmichael had received approval from the black leadership in Greenwood to put up the tent.
But then the white power there had overruled these blacks and told Stokely Carmichael couldn't put up the tent.
Of course Stokely Carmichael, the guy that he was and like most of us, it's our school, it's our community.
He's going to erect a tent anyway. So now he's in jail.
The marches are on their way to Greenwood, don't know nothing about what's happening in Greenwood.
They are headed there with the understanding that we're going to be able to put up here.
Okay, so now that Stokely Carmichael is in jail and the marches are coming, Stokely Carmichael, James Jones, and whoever they saw the party, got together and talked.
I said that we are going to stay in Greenwood. So how are we going to do it?
SNCC had once had an office in Greenwood. Our last SNCC office was right around the corner from a big black par that opened on all sides.
He said, what we're going to do, we're going to put up in this par. He said, well they gave it to him.
He said, look what we do is we send the run back to meet the marches and tell them to come in the Greenwood by this rock.
We send them and just tell them what's happening that we're going to stay in Greenwood.
Don't tell them officials, the highway patrolmen and the local sheriffs and all of them up front and in the real.
So we went along the route that we wanted them to come when this guy was on his way back.
Cleve, and James Jones went to get Stokely Carmichael out of jail and the marches are approaching the city limits of Greenwood.
And we were out there telling people along this route that Stokely Carmichael coming to town, the marches are coming to stay here tonight, get out to the par.
We were thinking that maybe we'd have a few people because now this park is right in the heart of the black community.
So we, some people there who knew us from the past agreed to go to houses all around the park and tell them to come to the park.
Man, when we got there in Stokely Carmichael and the winning got Stokely Carmichael out of jail.
All the way when he was walking from where we had, the crowd was so big that we had to park the car and walk to the park.
And about two streets, three streets over.
Now the policemen were out there on the highway.
They didn't know what happened while the marches disappeared, you know, from from from from following them.
And then the ones behind trying to communicate with them.
But by now we are in Greenwood and circling that park and the world we had told them that as soon as you circled the park,
stop your cars, jump out and fill up the park.
But the park's now all ready for the people there in Greenwood.
So now we just got that whole area.
And so somebody said, well, what are they going to do?
They said, well, they'll have to kill us all.
And what would the and the news media is there now.
You remember now Stokely Carmichael coming all the way there.
And he said, we, us black people, can't do nothing that the white people can't take away from us.
He said, we ain't got no counter-power.
We need some black power.
We need some black power all the way there.
And soon as he stepped up there on the stage with the target and mentioned the black power, the news media.
They defined black power for us as you know, immediately.
And so Stokely Carmichael, but now you know black power originally came for Willie Ricks, one of Stokely Carmichael's comrades, who had been talking about black power all along.
But now you think about this in Fannie Lou Hamer, defined black power for us.
You think about this.
You're talking about registering blacks to vote in rural Alabama, rural Georgia, where we are majority of the population, and in bigger cities, where we are majority.
Now what are you going to get out of that?
You got thousands of blacks, hundreds of blacks who never registered to vote.
Now they're getting the chance to register voter as a result of the voting rights act and federal registrals.
Now black voters are going to be black power.
I mean, Stokely Carmichael said if we had said color power, everything would have been alright.
But the word black frightened people.
And black power.
And so my paper talks about what happened, how we did that.
And about King coming to speaking in the middle of the meeting, Fannie Lou Ham was group.
Fannie Lou had to go somewhere else.
She was not at the meeting at the courthouse.
I was there.
And if you look at that marker, at the par, there I am standing right there by Stokely Carmichael.
See, when Stokely Carmichael came into office, he named me one of his comrades in Mississippi and gave me the responsibility to pull together his people in his folk in Mississippi
and bring all of our cars and things into one location.
And then who to go from that.
So black power got to frighten people as a result of the media because after all, I consider what we have now, especially in these areas, is black power.
And black power only means, Miss Amy said, that we want to help determine some of our destiny to have something to say about our lives.
It's the media and the scared people who got frightened about that because all Americans have the right to vote.
I mean, the vote, it's the essence of our democracy.
So there ought not to be a need for a voting rights act.
Why?
Because all Americans ought to be able to vote.
And it ought not to be, and it ought to be such an amendment that forbids anybody to just take you.
You know, states ought not to be allowed to take it.
It ought to be a national effort because it's America.
But we wouldn't have Barack Obama in office if we didn't get, hadn't got a little power.
And you know, freedom somewhere and all of this with these young white people coming down here that young people in this country put the boy in office.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming and recalling this.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.